So Destiny was wearing the butt plug in front of Tom.
>> During So during like during his regular social interactions
with with Tom, he was just plugged up and told Tom this and he
was just okay with >> how is this a 2-hour interview just
trying to like Tom's career and Destiny gets like the worst shot
in it? Somehow somehow Destiny gets hit the hardest in like a
two-hour interview from Tom's long-term exes from one of his
long-term exes. And there's just like a it's like a throwaway
line about Destiny and he's the most person in this interview.
That's That's crazy. >> What this?
>> Null,
you know, ex Josh over here. Ex Josh, dude. Null from Kiwi Farms,
the owner of Kiwi Farms went live today. It's a little weird.
I There's like some weird stuff about this. He basically went
live with Katie, the Left 4 Dead girl, the Clorox Katy girl,
and Sacramento, the two the two women from the Kiwi Farms thread
who were leaking things about Turkey Tom. And he had like exclusive
access. They like emailed them and stuff and then they got on
a stream with them. Dude, I It's like weird. It's like I don't
know if there's a conflict of interest there. Maybe not. It's
just It's a little odd to me. I don't know how to explain it,
man. It's a little odd, though.
Anyway, so they went on today.
He interviewed both of these girls today and we're going to check
that interview out right now. Okay. Right. Right. R right now.
Okay. So, he's going to be asking questions. My read on this
from what I saw
was that things got weird. Things got like really weird for me.
Like null was asking questions that were like he wasn't Null
was not trying to be a journalist. Okay. Null is not trying to
be a journalist in this. He is literally just trying to like
farm Turkey Tom's personal details to the maximum to the utmost
maximum limit. Okay,
this is the closest null will get to a threesome. Oh, that's
another thing null does. Okay, null actually starts explicitly
talking about what's normal in and I'm like, bro, what
bruh? You what? Null. What? What? What? Let's check it out. Meowies.
way >> having conversation today with uh Sacramento who
has been posting on the Kiwi Farms about Turkey Tom and Katie
who is her friend who also has known Turkey Tom and is also posting
on the forum. Um so just to get right into it, we're going to
talk to Katie at first and I'm just going to ask that she uh
tell whatever she wants to say from when she met Tom all the
way up to when they stopped knowing each other and then uh we'll
hear from Sacramento. Okay. So,
>> so do we need I don't know if we need any quick rundown
on these girls. Sacramento is the girl who was dating Tom for
I think 7 months. Okay. She dated Tom for seven months. She's
the one who screenshotted the match. There's like a lot of questions
we could ask over time. Kark Katie is the girl who is sort of
adjacent to the fish tank crowd and was already into like egirl.
Sorry, like being an egirl online. Like she had a she was very
much in these crowds already. She would have known who Turkey
Tom was. It was not like um she didn't go in blind at all. She's
not like a >> Uh Katie, hello.
>> Can you hear me?
>> Yes, I think everything's fine. I already messed up
my audio, but I think it should be fine. Okay, so how'd you meet
Turkey Tom? >> Um I met him on Instagram in like late
He started liking my stories and then he followed me on Instagram
and then
I think he DM'd me first and just like swiped up on one of my
stories and was like pretty. And I was like, "Oh my god, Turkey
Tom."
>> Oh my god, Turkey Tom. >> This is crazy. And then
we just like started talking like flirting back and forth and
then quickly he was like wanted to fly me out and then so am
I going too fast or like I feel like >> No, no, you're
fine. But uh >> if I want to interrupt I'll just I'll just
ask like for instance how long was it between he swiped on Instagram
to hey I'm going to pay to fly you out to to
I met him like probably December
uh of 2023 and then by January 2024 I was flown out. So like
a month, not
>> Okay. Um and would you say did it feel serious? Did
it feel like just like a hookup or? Um, I mean, you I I'm not
dumb, so you know, you can never really tell with like an with
like an internet personality or something if they're like trying
to date you or whatever. And so,
>> dude, I I just watch how Null is like Null's pushing
them to
I feel like Null is harshly like forcing narrative into this.
It's really funny. I like went there with like no intentions
of like thinking that he was going to like try to marry me or
anything like that, but he was like
>> very like he not to I hate the term like love bomb,
but he's a like love bomb for sure was like hella affectionate
but also like beating me but during
>> but otherwise would like sit there and like like compliment
me and like be affectionate and like took me to like guns and
ice skating and stuff and so I couldn't really tell if there
was something from it. But I could tell he liked me more than
just like
a hit and quit cuz then I like I did end up seeing him again.
>> Okay. So, in that month, when you say love bombing,
was it like I love you or was it like, "Oh, you're you're so
pretty and just like giving lots of
>> After I saw him the first time, after that he started
being like, "I love you. I like you're so awesome. Like, other
girls aren't like you. Like, this is perfect. Oh my god.
>> Okay. So, um >> but before meeting him, he would
just like compliment me a lot and stuff.
>> And uh so you came over, how long did you stay?
>> About I would say like fiveish, like five or six days.
>> Okay. It's a pretty good trip. And um
>> we're waiting it. Listen, they laid groundwork for a
little bit. We're waiting to get We want to get into the meme
potatoes. Okay. Leaks would have been more I mean they're already
kind of weird full of hell. I don't know if that was really required
to be Yeah, sure. Leaks would have been more interesting. Leaks
would have been more interesting if Tom had like a torture basement
where he was like a serial killer actually. But alas, we have
to deal with real. >> Do you mind telling me where where
you're from and where where his place is? Like what state? >> So
at the time I was living in San Francisco, California.
So I was I was flying literally across the country to Portland,
Maine.
And so it' be like literally an entire day of flying.
>> Yeah, I imagine. So it's probably like a >> like
a what 10 10 hour trip in total >> at least. Yeah, for
sure.
>> Okay. Um, so then after 5 days, I guess you flew back
and did you guys stay in contact? Yeah, after the first time
I flew back, we stayed in contact and he was like calling me
a lot. And then that's when I got the two videos of him saying
night and talking about like holding me down and the whole Game
of Thrones elf thing. And >> uh the Game of Thrones elf
thing. Uh not in a not joking sense. I'm pretty confident that
just means Daenerys. Like I I know that we had the whole conversation.
I was mostly just laughing and like leaning into that because
we were all, you know, kneeling on dickers that night. It's probably
Daenerys. It's like almost certainly Daenerys.
Um, there are no elves in Game of Thrones. There's the children
of the forest and there are the children of the forest, but that's
not what Tom means.
It's just like they're not prominent characters.
He would need to know Game of Thrones really, really well to
be referencing that, right? Yeah. So, >> that's a bit much.
Hold up. >> Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. >> Uh, how
long Sorry. How long ago was this? And how old were you two when
this >> So, I'm 23 now. So, I was like 20 20 21 I think.
Like 21 by that time or about to be
>> and he was um >> he's my age also. Yeah, he's
like 21. >> Cool. Um,
so then you guys were apart
and uh these were when you got the the voicemails in particular
one that you mentioned. And was that like,
let me rephrase that. Did it feel like it was a exclusive thing
after you went back to San Francisco? Did it feel like this is
a relationship and we're not seeing other people now? >> Not
fully that it was a relationship, but definitely, you know, the
>> Do you see how like Null is Null's obviously always
pushing back to like what I would say is he's trying to make
Tom look worse like with every question. I feel like Null is
intentionally like narrative driving the whole time. Would you
say like he like told you that
you were you were seeing each other like this was a this was
a you know you were an item you were exclusive at this point
and she's like no no he's always asking the questions that make
Tom look worse cuz I believe she's already said that when she
went back Thomas had with more people right >> term situationship
something like that where like it did seem like we were exclusive
especially with the way he would like talk >> like at that
point
and so I wouldn't say cuz that's what like I wouldn't say we
ever dated. We were more just like a fling cuz I never like he
never like asked me to be his girlfriend straight out and then
but like he also never like but he would tell me he wasn't having
sex with other girls and stuff.
>> Okay. Um, so it was during this break where
you were receiving like voice messages from him and I remember
the one that really stuck out is he said it's very awkward and
I'm going to try to give him the benefit of a doubt and I'm wondering
if you can fill this in for me because it was speculated.
>> Uh, he says something like there's nothing better than
night and that's what it really sounds like. Like he really puts
emphasis
on the P and night.
Okay, the night audio to me, the night audio is obviously a joke.
It's said in the exact way that Tom does his joking cadence.
It's like I like night. I'm a big fan of night. I like night
room. He's like he's doing a whole he's doing a bit where he's
like jo he's joking. He's clearly joking around with the person.
That audio is not suspicious. That audio is like whatever who
cares.
And I think people who take it seriously and
null has like another explanation for this. It's really not a
big deal. >> It was explained to me that there is a DLC
for Elden Rings called Night Rain and he might be referring to
that. Would >> or Elden Ring? >> Do you know Night
Res
I will say that there's a reason that he said night, but I don't
want to air out a business that is like a not known thing, but
someone else like someone else has said night before and I guess
that's like and he very much liked it, but he and he also was
like into like
CNC type stuff. So he would use it >> When you say CNC,
you mean consensual, non-consentual like replay? >> Yeah.
like like we like like from what I could tell cuz like
>> I don't know what that means. I would want to know what
the other thing is. Is that not just on the internet? What is
she doing a what is he doing a reference to with night that he
can do the reference that she can't tell anybody else cuz nobody
else knows
the is he talking about? What do you mean? What is So she's saying
that like Tom knows about this is referencing something else
but I don't want to blow up other people's things. Like what
is sexomnia? I'm certain of it. I don't think so. I don't maybe
maybe cuz I do think this girl talks about how obsessed he is
with Destiny at about this exact time. So >> I don't want
to like get ahead of myself, so I won't explain too much at once,
but like we'll get into like the whole dynamics later, but um
it it seemed like he would say night sometimes and it would give
like oh he was about like he wants to me or sometimes it'd be
night and it's like haha city like like funny joke. So it was
like >> so I think that's >> there's no way that
he was referring to a game is >> no no he's not saying
night rain >> and you're and you're 100% certain of that
because of context that's not in that conversation.
>> Yes 100%.
many of times
>> during the how many times did you fly out to meet him
>> twice. Okay. And before how long how long was the gap
between the first time and the second time?
>> Um like threeish weeks.
>> Okay. And um so during that they had the night message.
Was there anything else that was like that stands out in memory
during that time?
He would just te like text me very like vulgar like gooner type
stuff about like you like like same things as like he was saying
on the phone of like oh you're so small and I'm so big and I'm
so strong and I and like oh like I be I like gave you a bruise
and blah blah blah or and like he would like be like ew I don't
even want to say these types of words. It's so like gross to
say, but you would just, you know, like say, >> okay, no,
it's not. It's not gross. No, it's not gross. It is literally
the dynamic.
If you think it's gross, say it's gross in the moment or like,
dude, I Yeah, people say weird when they're going to have sex
relationship. People say weird. It's just It's so annoying to
me that now she's just like It's so It's so weird how he talked
about how he's like strong. It's like like No, it's not. I don't.
That's like normal talk. That's normal talk. Okay. >> They
like weird sex things and
like throughout
waiting to like go like before I went back.
>> Did it feel like the um the size difference was like
a really big thing to him like like he was really into >> Sorry.
It's really funny that the other girl's not even involved in
the conversation yet and she has to immediately jump in and go,
"Yeah, yeah, no. No, it's a big deal. No, the size difference
thing is a big deal. Size queen Tom. No, it's not talking about
his dick size. That is talking about the size difference of as
in he's like a big person. They're little itty bitty girls. Okay,
that's like the thing. Yes, both of these girls are being interviewed
at the same time. It's both Katie and
Yes, it's both of the girls who have accused Tom of stuff. They're
on the call together >> for both of you.
>> How tall is he? >> 5'8.
I was going to say like I don't know like five
>> like half a foot taller than Queman which is very short.
Okay. >> At most. >> Okay. How tall are you guys?
>> Actually, wait. This I just No, he's dead ass like 5'8.
Yeah, you're right. Because when I met him, I wore platforms
and I was his height.
>> So, I was going to ask, are you guys like like 5 foot
even or something? >> I'm 5'3. I would say most men probably
prefer women who are like smaller, right? Um, yeah, I mentioned
it wrong. Um, I So, Cringle Kesh, I think most men want somebody
who's smaller, but they don't want somebody who's like like I
think really focusing in on that and constantly referencing how
awesome it is that they have like
younger girl features. I I think there's something going on there
that is a little odd,
but we'll see. We'll see. We'll see. We'll
Um, questions I wanted asked.
Dude, I don't really know that there's like much for questions
I wanted asked specifically except maybe like stuff about did
you ask for evidence? There's one thing that's in here that's
very good. Like basically, hey, did you ask him to like one did
you what when did you ask him to stop doing things? What was
his reaction to being asked to stop doing things? Any uh both
the filming, the physical play, right? And then essentially what
was his reactions to those were like things I wanted to focus
on but I think we wait to get to that. >> Um I'm like 5'5
but I'm very
uh petite built I guess.
>> Okay.
So
so he would just mention that a lot that you you guys were like
very petite and and small.
>> Did he ever um ask you to wear specific
>> Not like per se. That's like so annoying. It's literally
just like explain to me what you're saying. Like don't just say,
"Oh my god, don't do a moral signal." And then go when I'm like,
"Oh, why are you being an Fslur?" You're like, "Oh my god. Oh
my god.
>> Calm down, man." >> But he definitely Sacramento
can attest to this, too. Would like kind of try to push stuff
on to you. Like he would buy like specific gifts. So, like you
would wear it because it's like something he bought you and it's
like and it's a gift, but it's but it's not like he would be
like put this on, but he would buy like weird like Hello Kitty
attire and like would ask like if if we were into like Hello
Kitty or dolls and stuff like that.
>> That is a little interesting. Did Did he do this with
a bunch of his girls? So, the context for the Clorox Katy girl
is I think that's I think the Clorox Katy girl is his rebound
after Kai. That's what she was told or that's what she says in
this is she's the second girl Tom's ever slept with. Okay. So,
she's the rebound after Kai. And the idea that Tom is like, "Wait,
are you into this stuff, too?" That's a little odd. It's a little
odd. >> And so, I think
>> Monster High >> Monster High.
>> Oh, man. >> It's because of Kai literally.
>> Okay. So, he was trying to find like another like he
was in I guess age play. I mean, I don't want to like just jump
to that and say like, "Oh, he's definitely looking for age play."
But like Monster
I don't want to like say like put the words out like that, but
also at the same time, I mean, if you're looking for a [__]
who's into dolls and Hello Kitty and Velcro children's shoes,
then like >> Yeah, that's like in the kids aisle at Walmart.
This is the Monster High stuff.
>> Okay. What is this? Monster High.
High. Monster High shoes.
Monster High collection.
is like this.
Okay.
Maybe
it's like shoes like this. Okay. I see.
Okay. I could see why that would be a little weird.
>> Interesting. Um, so he he would
>> uh So that girl is just self-reporting. What do you
mean, Riyle? You said that girl is just self What does that mean?
That girl is just self-reporting.
I actually don't know what What could you possibly mean there?
They're like Bratz dolls. Yeah, that's what I I Yeah, that's
the impression I get cuz she's not saying she's into that. See,
she's saying she wasn't into that and Tom was buying that [__]
as
So, I don't think she's really self-reporting. She's saying it's
weird that Tom was buying this stuff as gifts when I didn't ask
for it and then he was asking if I like this stuff. >> Would
I mean that's what I was I was I was asking for like did he give
you clothes that was like this is like saccharine light pastels
and stuff?
>> Yes. for my birthday gift. He bought me a whole bunch
of Hello Kitty type stuff. Like in some of the pictures of the
age player girl, um Ellie, she's wearing these Hello Kitty pajamas
and he bought me like those exact same type of pajamas and other
like stuffed animals, stuff like that. Um yeah. >> So that
could be a little weird because obviously if you get something
as a gift for someone, you're kind of hoping they'll wear it.
I think I think that's your way of like sort of saying this is
what I like like and maybe you could say no. It seems that way
though that you're sort of pushing that you're pushing them in
that direction.
It's a just a little ah you know it's a little ah a little >> um
so since you
Katie was was vaguely aware of I guess not even vaguely like
you knew who he was but you say that you you didn't know him
at all. Right. And I
I believe they're both saying that that was not the they were
really into. Yes. Like they I believe so that they're both saying,
"Yeah, that's not my >> Switch back, but I have a quick
question. Did that seem out of place? Like you don't know this
guy and he's buying like Hello Kitty, Monster High, and stuff."
It's like, did that seem like weird or
>> Um, I wanted to clarify that. I figured out who he was
like very quickly. Um, so yeah, I knew about his online presence
like pretty much as soon as >> we met till the end of our
relationship, but I wasn't like super into
>> YouTube world or whatever. So like I knew that he had
a YouTube channel, but I wasn't like super into it. >> But
did you feel that the the gifts like the clothing and toys and
stuff? >> That was not Wait, what did she just Why did
she she just answered
not a question null asked. Null asked about the gifts and you're
like, "Yeah, I figured out who he was online pretty quickly."
Huh.
That is, by the way, another question that will get asked that
is like sort of relevant and important, but it's so she just
wasn't listening. I don't even I don't know where that came from.
That's >> were weird or did
>> Okay. It did.
>> Like all of it like the clothes too was like this is
weird. >> Yes. because I never expressed any like interest
in like oh I love Hello Kitty and I want more Hello Kitty stuff
like I don't know. >> Okay, last question then I'll I'll
switch back to the >> So she's saying like I literally
never mentioned this to her >> interest and like oh I love
Hello Kitty and I want Yes. >> Like all of it like the
clothes too is like this is weird. >> So she's weirded
out. >> Yes. because I never expressed any like interest
in like, oh, I love Hello Kitty and I want more Hello Kitty.
>> All right.
>> Yes. So, she never expressed any interest in this at
all.
No interest whatsoever.
And yet, she's still getting this as >> I don't know. >> Kind
of weird. Okay, last question, then I'll I'll switch back to
the timeline. But did you ever like deliberately express an interest
like, "Oh, I would like this as a gift." and then just not get
it cuz it didn't match like what we know now in terms of what
his interests >> Sorry, that's like an obuse question.
>> I would say yes, Sack, because of the flower situation.
>> Oh my god, the flower situation. Yes, I did ask Tom
to buy me flowers and he did not seem to understand why a woman
in a relationship with a man would want flowers ever. Um, he
actually called his mom and asked why it would be important to
ever buy a woman flowers and that was like the only time I ever
asked him for something.
Um, but the rest of it >> in front of you to ask about
why >> this is this is super this is like one of the more
damning pieces of information that comes out during this whole
thing where he's like why would a why why would any woman want
flowers? And then he's like I called my mom. She said women do
want flowers. That's weird, man. >> Do women like flowers?
>> Um, no. But he had told me that he called her to ask
why.
Yeah. Sorry.
>> Okay. Okay then. So, in in this gap then between the
two meetups. Did
Did anything else happened? There was another voicemail that
you shared, right? Do you remember what that was? Yeah, that's
the one that's like cuz there's the the night one and then there's
the like oh you're so small and I'm so big and like when I was
holding you down I thought I was going to break your arms or
so. He says something to those to like that like something like
>> I think it was her who said she felt like her arms going
to get broken. >> And then he compares have like my small
and like having sex with me to like having with a fairy from
Game of
No, no. He compared it to the elf girl from Game of Thrones.
You said you were like a fair. You were like, "Yes, yes. I'm
like a fairy on acid." What's that quote from Skins? I'm like
a fairy on acid. That's her quote, not his quote. Why do I know
her voicemails better than she does? That's kind of weird. That's
kind of odd. Anyway, I I think that's weird. But I guess I've
been covering this stuff like fairly religiously since it came
out. So maybe that's really what it comes down to. Damn. >> Okay.
So that's another thing that I don't understand. Maybe you guys
Did you guys watch Game of Thrones? I have not watched Game of
Thrones. >> Nobody knows what he's talking about. >> I
saw people tweaking a little bit in the in the threads about
that, like debating which girl it was. I have no idea. He never
showed me which one he like meant in or like which one came to
mind. And I also didn't ask because I was like, "This is such
a weird thing to say. Aren't they all 12?"
>> There it's I don't even want to get into it, but there's
like
And I also didn't ask because I was like, "This is such a weird
thing to say. Aren't they all 12?"
>> There it's I don't even want to get into it, but there's
like no clear understanding. Nobody has any idea what that means.
What he says, but she's 14. There's some Yeah, there's like an
elf character that is in one of the spin-offs as a child and
like is like 14 at the youngest.
>> An elf. Wait, what?
An elf character? An elf character in one of the spin-offs
that I mean there's only House of the Dragon. There's an elf
character in House of the Dragon.
I think I think he's has no idea what he's talking about.
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure there's no elves in Game of Thrones.
But Daenerys is pretty young at the beginning, but
books. What book?
Which book? He said he didn't watch it. Okay. He's had no idea
what he's talking about. All right. Um, there are no elf girls.
I've seen some people suggest Wildlings. I think Wildlings is
even stupid. Even more dumb. I don't think you say elf for wildlings.
Those are like opposites.
The elf girl is almost certainly just
She kind of looks like an elf. She kind of dresses like an elf.
It I could see that being a mistake you make. Okay. That she
looks like No, no. The children of the forest thing is actually
just
No, the children of the forest thing is just dumb.
They're too big though. They're not at the beginning. They're
not.
And plus
the the thing that lends lends the most credence to this is that
Daenerys is literally in the first season. You guys are are focusing
in on the wrong things. It's so it's so dumb. He obviously doesn't
mean the children of the forest cuz one
if if he's like a big fan of the show, he would say children
of the forest,
If he's a big fan of the show, he would say children of the forest.
If he's not a big fan of the show, then I don't even know if
he knows who the children of the forest the children of the forest
are or has even seen them before.
Like you either know or you don't know. It's actually it's like
completely brain damaged to think he means the uh the children
of the forest to be honest with you. It's like completely brain
damaged. I I went along with it was like memeing for the sake
of like okay we're dickers kind of but it's obviously not the
children of the forest. Come on. It's there's just 0% chance
compared to calling the human an elf.
I you're coming at this as somebody who likes fantasy and thinks
that's weird. By the way, who looks more like an elf from Lord
of the Rings, Archandriel? Daenerys
or the children of the forest? Go ahead. I'm waiting. I'm waiting
for that the response to that. Who looks more like an elf? Daenerys
or one of the children of the forest? George R. Martin literally
describes the Targaryens as elf. Like, yeah, they're live of
feature. I already said all of this. I already explained this.
I don't even have to rejustify it. You're stupid if you think
it's the children of the forest. You're like an actual [__]
It's over. We don't have to discuss it anymore. That is done.
Okay. As the person who knows fantasy knows how people who think
about fantasy, even people who don't read it or watch it, you're
if you think otherwise
is like an adult at the latest, nobody really understands what
that means. So did
>> so the decision to fly back and meet him um was that
prompted by him or by you?
My birthday is in my >> No, mannequin. It's not prompted
off of a skins fairy comment she made. He said she looked like
the elf. He was [__] her like the elf girl from Game
of Thrones, right?
And then she said something about a fairy acid from Skins, but
he brought it up. He was the one who said that first. >> Is
that prompted by him or by you?
>> He My birthday is in my birthday is in March. And so
he was like, "Ooh, you should come see me for your birthday."
like I have to do this furry convention, but then you should
come and see me.
>> And I was like, wait, what?
>> He's Oh, cuz he's going Is that where he met um Meline
or Meowin?
>> Maybe. He just I know he like posted a video I think
on like Tom IRL or something of him at that furry >> of
him going to and he asked you to fly back for the furry convention.
No, right after he was like, >> uh, this is where it becomes
clear to me that Clorox Katie is probably also just interested
in like with Tom pretty significantly here, right? Where she's
I think she's trying to imply that he some furries at that convention.
I think she's very heavily leaning on this trying to say he some
furries at this convention. I don't think null picks it up cuz
he's on but she's I think she's trying to lean in that direction
and null doesn't pick it up.
So,
he's trying to Tom went there for work. I He maybe he a furry.
I don't know. But it seems unlikely. That doesn't really seem
to fit with any of the other [__] >> He was
like, "I'm going to go to the furry convention and then you should
come see me."
>> Oh, okay. That's interesting. So,
uh before I ask about that visit, anything else from the gap
that's that is interesting, worth touching on? Did he say anything
weird? I mean, I've kind I kind of went over most of it of him
just being like overall like pushy and weird and like like age
bay almost with the like the things he would say.
>> Okay. Um and then you fly back and how did that go?
How long did you >> Horrible. That was the worst experience
of my life, I think. >> Wow. Okay.
So, was that also 5 days?
>> No. Uh I think like 5 days total like of me like I flew
in and then like I stayed with him for real.
>> Uh I think in the show she's canonically a minor as
well though guys. Even though she's a she's way younger in the
books. I think in the show although it's an adult actress she
is playing a character that is younger even in the show by the
show standards.
Okay. Just so we know. Just so we know just so we're clear. >> For
real three days and I flew back on the fifth day. >> You
flew back early? >> Yeah. He actually Well, okay. when
he flies girls out, he doesn't buy them a flight home. He flies
you out and then he's like and then he's like, "I'll buy your
flight home when you get here."
>> that's weird. >> Which already when I was like
telling That's why all my friends thought I was a victim from
the jump is like he acted really weird and also would do things
like that. And so all my like normal friends were like, "This
is weird. Like you're a victim right now and you're just not
realizing."
>> I Is that even that weird? I they're characterizing
the one-way flight as super odd. I don't know if it's that weird.
Like they just kind of they just kind of manufacture it as being
weird.
I don't see why it's weird.
I think I think if he like was keeping them there past when they
wanted to be there, then sure.
Right. But I I don't think it's that odd. No, it's not a cost
split thing. I don't think he was planning to make them pay for
the flight back. I think he was just like, "Oh, well, when you
want to go back, I'll I'll just book you a fight a flight back."
Like, if he said if he said, "I'm not going to mention the flight
back." Or, "I don't know." Like, she didn't even ask a question.
If she thought it was weird. If she really thought that was weird
or like uh, you know, really bad or spooky in any way, why didn't
she just ask a question of like, "Yeah, what what if I want to
come back fast?" And then he goes, "Oh, well, I'll just buy you
a flight or I'll give you some money to so you can fly back or
Nah, he trapped him there with him. No way to get back. No, I
don't think so. I think it's like kind of stupid to look at it
this way. And they just say this like nobody's going to watch
this and ask questions.
The one-way flight is not that odd. Yeah, cuz it I'm sorry. It's
not that odd cuz it's like what if I assume people some people
would want to cancel it, right? They they want to um Sorry. Some
people want to stay more than like a weekend or something and
then what is he going to do? Cancel a flight, rebook it?
You buy one way and then it's like, "Oh, for having fun after
two days, maybe you want to stay longer and then, you know, you
could book, we'll book a flight back after."
Jtock 100% buy. I don't buy flights. I I'm not, that's not a
thing. But I'm telling you that it like makes total sense if
he was just inviting this girl over. If he actually, let's say
he wasn't trying to just Let's say he's trying to figure out
like if he's going to date somebody. It doesn't feel weird that
he would buy a one-way ticket. Wait, where is the woman's safety
affected full of hell? By a one-way flight. That's just THINK
THESE ARE ADULT WOMEN. THESE ARE ADULT WOMEN that exist in the
world that are perfectly capable of buying their own flights
back, of having credit cards.
Are we out of our minds right now? What are we doing? They could
go if things go badly, they just go get their own hotel and then
they fly back. What are we talking about here?
I'm sorry. There are a lot of people in chat who are like, "No,
it is kind of weird, actually." No, it's not. It's not even a
little bit weird. Why are people acting like it's weird? It's
just not. It's straight up not weird. In fact, I I think you're
If you think it's weird,
what are their ages again? I think this girl was like 20, 22.
This girl was fine. They're all fine. And then the other girl,
she he lived in the same city as her. >> And that's like
how I got all those
>> Okay. Cuz you were you were on edge. You had been warned
that there might be something weird going on. >> Yeah.
And my friend was spending the night with me and was listening
to the conversation cuz he would like beg to call me like every
night. And so I was like, "Final answer." And she was listening
and she was like, "What the [__] is this man saying
to you?"
>> Okay. So what what was so terrible about the second
visit? >> Okay. So fun. This is kind of
>> what if the person can't afford to go home? Then say,
"Hey, uh, I I want to I want a two-way flight.
Hey, I want a two-way flight. Hey, I want a flight back, too.
Excuse me.
Hey, I don't feel comfortable with this." If you think it's weird,
if you're not totally into it, hey, I'm uncomfortable with that.
I'm going to fly back.
So, get me a two-way flight. I'll come over there. I'll hang
out, but give me a two-way flight.
Let's plan. By the way, if if he wasn't seeking a relationship,
if he just wanted to Isn't it way more likely that he would demand
a two-way flight?
To me, it makes way more sense if he just wants to her, then
you have a two-way flight. So, she's got an exit date. Hello.
He's not hurting for money. This guy's a millionaire at like
20 at this point. He's like 21 and a millionaire. If he just
wanted to this girl, then you get her to a flight so you can
send her away. Obviously, no. I don't think she was actually
worried about this. I don't think she was actually scared about
this. I think this is total. I think this is like an invented
problem that isn't real. I think she's like pretending this is
a problem. And this is one of the things where I'm not going
to let this part build up like it's actually something that matters,
right? Cuz it's not. This is totally irrelevant. It's totally
[__] stupid and anybody supporting this is we continue.
It's going to sound like it's like a little bit of a ramble in
a sense cuz it's like there's so the dream like the dream George
not found drama was happening at the at the time with this girl
named Katie and um only reason I know about it is cuz I was at
his house and he was streaming literally for two days straight
just sitting in his room making me sit in the corner silently
while he just streamed all day talking about how this was like
a liar and a stupid and like her like consent Is it real? And
like in
>> Okay, dude. What
is that? Was that Tom's take from Katie
I'm starting to get I'm starting to get a little annoyed here.
Do I have to go look up Tom's Katy Bugs coverage?
Consent isn't real. Did Tom really Is that a quote? Tom
Turkey Tom,
infamous YouTuber Turkey Tom said consent is not real.
Really?
>> silently listen >> while he just
>> So he said, "Hey, shut the [__] up. Sit
in the corner. I'm streaming about this stupid I'm streaming
about this stupid [__] Katy Bugs." Look at this stupid
[__] Katie Bugs over here.
>> Screamed all day talking about how this [__]
was like a liar and a stupid and like her like consent.
>> A liar. A stupid and consent isn't real. >> Isn't
real and like insane. It's just like insanity in the way like
bruh.
No he didn't. I was around at that time. Tom was coming in my
Discord at that time. There's no way that I would have heard
that I would have seen that and been like, "Oh, oh, Tom's like
going out of his mind on this."
There's There's no way that I missed it if that was what he said.
>> I don't even know anything about that situation. So,
like I don't know if there was like actual drama there, but just
listening to how he was talking about like a girl getting I was
like, "Oh my god, no wonder he's beating me." Like this is this
man is insane.
>> A girl getting
like and I literally ended up like not like >> Hold on,
hold on. Here's somebody. >> This video is intended as
a companion piece to my video on the supposed frequency of false
accusations which you can find link in this It goes over something
reacting to another person's reaction to the over publication
of now here I am talking about this great and those people spectating
have of course taken sites I see a lot of difficult about these
accusations their severity will led to them and I want to talk
more >> I just want to see this guy's criticism
has spoken about I don't know how to make a judgement and it's
not something I'm uncomfortable doing >> okay here's where
understanding what assault actually is you can see this full
effect of how you Tom Dark better known as Ty describes Katy's
experience contrasting what he thinks a real assault look like
everyone does that makes evil then you do right when you get
chat in front of everyone if you're immediately takes down show
through your jeans you're holding your rifle with his bowing
knife that's one thing >> here we can see that Tom is relying
on the stereotypical signs of an assault that would show signs
a struggle or physical violence despite this not typically being
>> Dude, this is some spooky ass music. What the? >> And
again, I'm not trying to make any definitive claims on Katie's
story or what happened that night, nor am I trying to invalidate
the experiences of anyone who did have something like that happen
to them. Rather, I want to point out the one-dimensional view
of things that people often have when talking about these crimes
and the harmful and restrictive effect this has on the way that
we think about them. Tom then goes on to say that in every single
encounter, you have a responsibility to advocate for yourself
if you're uncomfortable, going so far as to place blame on Katie
for not doing so. As a shy person, I cannot speak up in front
of him and everyone else. Well, that's your fault. That's not
his fault. If you're shy, then don't get drunk and cuddle with
people. Like, I don't know what to say. Like, that's your fault.
You have a responsibility to advocate for yourself in certain
situations. Is that a shocking thing to say? >> And again,
it's not technically wrong to say that people should look after
themselves, but once again, put that in contrast with how a lot
of real assaults actually occur. And you >> Okay, but here's
the thing. I don't think Katie got touched anywhere particularly
sensitive, right? Like, I don't think Katie Katie was not like,
"Dude, Katie was not assaulted. Katie was not groped significantly
like like Katie basically I think this guy had every reason this
guy had every reason to think Katie was like kind of into him
and if I remember correctly it wasn't that he what did he like
get halfway up her chest like he didn't even grab boob he didn't
even he didn't even get to nipple and then he was like oh never
mind
I I don't think he got I think he got like up towards chest I
think he was migrating to chest and got like he groped her which
came out later
did he grab a
cuz she didn't grab she didn't say he grabbed it.
>> It's very well documented that people who are being
assaulted often freeze up as a natural fear response to what
they're experiencing. Tom doesn't account for this though because
he's already made up his mind as to how a credible victim acts
based on what he thinks is true. His perception >> uh ex
normie me I've got I've got the um I know that Mike Smalls Jr.
is the CX community's Terry Cruz. Okay, I'm aware of this. I've
got it in the docket. All right, it's it's locked into the docket.
We're gonna do it. Don't worry. I know. Ice beside grab somebody's
and we're gonna cover it. All right. We're gonna cover this wall
to wall. We're gonna have wallto-wall dick grabbing coverage.
All right. And is based on lazy stereotypes rather than the documented
facts. And this reliance on lazy stereotypical thinking rather
than any appreciation for the true dynamic of assault leads to
Tom advocating against the very simple solution to a lot of these
problems. That of course being vocal consent.
vocal consent is not always a thing. And I the funny thing about
this is in my opinion is that vocal consent doesn't really need
to be a thing a thing for a lot of people for a lot of interactions
but man vocal consent would have saved Tom here. He would have
it would have saved him from a lot of really bad.
So why in most cases I'm like, you know, you don't need vocal
consent. You can gradually progress through physical situations
and it's like not that bad, right? I I do think that's broadly
true, but for Tom, perhaps verbal consent should be required.
Tom's the guy who escalates way too fast. Tom, ironically, pulled
a George not found in a far worse sense. That's the accusation.
Okay, we But we'll never know if it's otherwise. It's just like
in the George situation, we had to deal with the accusation,
right? Like you in a lot of situations, somebody's escalating
too fast. That's just going to come down to a judgment >> If
you're cautious about consent, why not ask? This is once again,
this is just not how things usually work. Like typically the
way people interact is much more human than this like robotic
like, "Excuse me, sir. Would you like to engage in of the gay
riot?" Well, yes sir, I would love to engage in steps to the
gay riot. Will you be planning on inserting your into my cavity?
Why yes, my surn contract here, a fine contract we will both
sign that will give me permission to assert my cavity and sexually
signed by a judge. And this is something that a lot of I don't
even know what to call them. anti
>> I do believe this is what she meant when she said consent
isn't real. Dude, just imagine there's some there's some egirl
sitting in the corner. There's some egirl sitting in a beanag
chair in his corner of his room while he's doing this stream.
Okay, she's just sitting there in the corner chilling and Tom's
doing this rant. He He does this impression to himself. She's
sitting off in like this corner to the right over here. Okay.
>> Excuse me, sir. Would you like to engage in of the gate
riot? Well, yes sir. I would love to engage into the gay rioty.
Will you be planning on inserting your into my cavity? Well,
yes, my concern fact I've drafted up contract here, a foreign
contract that we will both sign that will give me permission
to assert my interior cavity and signed by a >> And this
is something that a lot of I don't even know what to call them,
anti- vocal consent advocates love to bring up. The idea that
Dude, this is uh very unfunny. Uh
I mean, it's really popular to call Tom unfunny, but also Tom
does comedy bits that aren't for like I Dude, there's like a
big
I don't know how to explain it. There are a lot of total loser
fs slurs in these communities who like want to pretend that they're
better than most people and things that are for regular people
they don't like. Okay. Cuz they
it's like their way of feeling better than other people. It's
like their version of racism. Um their it's their version of
racism. Like for racists they're like, "Oh, I'm better than black
people. That's what's going to make me like better." Right? But
for a lot of people in these spaces, they're like, "Oh, actually,
like the thing that most people find funny is not funny to me.
I don't find that funny. They're like a loser." And it's like,
"No, they're not. Tom had like a massively popular stream." Tom
is a funny person. You could say Tom's not Tom's humor is not
for you. But Tom's obviously a funny person. He's made millions
of dollars being a funny person. I don't believe that this this
community, like all these communities are just totally niche.
Yeah, it's cream of viewers. Queen viewers are unbearable, dude.
Actually unbearable with the humor. You're so embarrassing. And
I guess I just have to start checking people on this. Quan, I
believe. Quan watches content 20 hours a day. Okay. Quan watches
content from the second he gets up until he goes to sleep. For
Queen, I believe it. For the rest of you people, you're lazy.
You have jobs. You don't actually watch it that much. You don't
actually care that much. You just copy what someone else has
said. Somebody else says, the most convincing person. Don't do
it. Okay. Tom is obviously a funny person.
Okay, maybe. Okay, Wendy. Yeah, but hold on, Wendy. Let's be
real. You are a Perry viewer, and that's the same group of people.
So, you could just You watch the less funny version of of Queenman
because you got made fun of by Quean. That's actually what's
happening here. Okay, you got made fun of by Queman, so you don't
like him anymore, so you watch the less funny version. It's the
exact same thing. The exact same pattern. It's the exact same
pattern playing out where Perry is like, "Oh, I'm like he hates
all popular things." I'm just sorry. I'm like I'm the person
who is actually like lived through being the cringe loser who
hates everything popular and now I'm like actually popular things
being social liking things other people like. That's a normal
human being thing. That's what normal human beings do.
Sorry. It's not just oh it's not just there's a whole bunch of
other people like this wringle. Don't worry about it. It's a
ton of people like this. No Tom's by the way you can say Tom's
not your cup of tea but just should be like oh it's not he's
never funny. He's trying to illustrate a point. He does like
a little in the- moment skit. It's a twoc skit on a stream, right?
It's not a prepared comedy bit. >> If you so much as ask
someone if they're okay with something, then it's the equivalent
of signing a contract and having a lawyer present. Signed by
Rick and Morty. They're both going to sign it. They're the official
trying to convince you to be a sheep. No, but here's the thing.
Some people are so scared of being sheep that they're
I'm trying to convince you to uh, you know, just be in touch
with what you actually like. You know what I'm saying? There's
like there's sheep and then there's the opposite of sheep, which
are still sheep.
Okay. Ironically, in this situation, you are actually black sheep.
You are like socially unlovable losers who are black sheep. Okay.
You're you're like the opposite of regular sheepers of this >> And
this is such a dishonest and smooth brain take that I struggle
to believe anyone actually believes this. There's a mile wide
gap between assault and having a written contract and a lawyer
present. Literally just any statement or question to check in
with how the other person is feeling. It doesn't have to be difficult.
So why do you try to make it sound so complicated? The only defense
I've ever seen of this stance is that asking for consent might
kill the mood, which [__] hell. Ignoring the thousands
of women who have expressed the exact opposite perspective. What
kind of thought process is that? Oh, what if we're in the heat
of the moment and things are getting steamy and hot and heavy?
What do you think? You're in the notebook. There's no reason
not to check in with the person.
There's like a
There's so many ways to get around this and it's so dumb that
people don't Here's the thing. I'm going to I'm going to go with
a wild wild
thing here. Okay. Minor consent violations are not that bad.
Okay. There's like a certain there's a set of hierarchies that
exist where if you're at one level of like physical intimacy
with somebody, you can try to escalate to the next set of that
hierarchy,
right? And not be like a
you can you can risk it for the biscuit and go up like one little
bit, right? And then basically what you need to do at that point
is you need to either ask in some way that's not totally cringe.
You don't say, "Can I do this?" you you like start going to do
it and you you measure their body language or you like do it
and then ask like hey is that is this kind of thing okay like
oh is that does that feel good is that good right you can do
it without being like totally cringe but what I would say is
what happens with a lot of these guys is they're and they don't
do the check-in ever do anything like that right they just go
they escalate escalate escalate escalate and then you're like
you're like grabbing a girl's or like trying to grope or like
in the m this misgiven an example of this where he like tries
to slide his hand down's pants without really having a good idea
of the vibe. It's like it's the multiple escalations without
being able to check in. That's that's what's wrong, right? It's
just the multiple escalations. That's that's where you run into
trouble. Okay?
It's
and like as you have less experience with a person, you should
be a little slower in progressing across that or be more direct
about the explicit consent, right? If you don't know somebody,
be more direct about like, hey, if you go to a bar and some girl
is like really horny and she just she decided you're the guy,
I'm going to [__] you tonight. Then you can just
be more open about it, right?
You just be like, "Oh, well, this is like what I'm into. What
are you into? Okay, cool. Let's go. Right. But like that's you
can be more explicit about it if you want. If that's what it
is and you're with at that moment. It's basic respect to make
sure that everyone involved is cool with it. And if it turns
out they're not, then well one better luck next time. But this
anti- vocal consent stance is contradictory to what Tom says
at another point in the video wherein he lambasts Katie for ascribing
a malicious intent to George's actions without knowing if this
was the case. She's putting thoughts in his mind as well. She's
putting attention in his head that he's is never expressed. >> So
on the one hand, it's silly to assume that you know what someone's
thinking. But then he also says this. >> How do I think
Cuddling automatically mean it was to turn? What? I have never
cuddled with a girl I didn't intend on. Has anyone ever kissing
someone isn't you? His dick is on your His dick is lined up with
your cavity. It's not You either are a liar or have no brain.
Either way, brain dead. >> So, which is it? Is she supposed
to know what he wants or is it silly to assume? >> Man,
if only there was some >> This is I This is By the way,
we're looking at the worst possible way of looking at Tom here.
Somebody who's basically arguing Tom is a Okay, data male. All
right.
And I still feel like most of Tom's stakes are pretty defensible
here. Most of Tom's stakes are totally fine here. It's totally
fine. Okay.
Obviously totally fine. Jesus, man. Jesus, man. What are we doing?
>> We We hung out. >> That's like That's the worst
look at what Tom was doing there, by the way. Like that's as
bad as you could look at it.
And I still feel like it's not close to what she's saying. Although,
I do get that he's saying, "Oh, when she says consent isn't real,"
he's saying, "Oh, don't do like informed. You don't have to do
like verbally informed consent at all times during situations
>> a lot for like the first day and then he was like streaming
a lot and then I literally was like non-verbal even when he wasn't
streaming we like were barely
>> oh yeah alien mode that that was what I said the second
he did the contract thing that's what I said she was talking
>> talking he told me I was a second body and then the
like the first time I went and saw him he told me I was the second
girl he had sex with and then the second time I went and saw
him he he made me watch the show you
And um
>> oh by the way there's going to be a lot of moments during
this that you want to say like oh Tom like Gigachad Tom Giga
Chad there's a there's going to be so many moments throughout
this where he's like
the sociopath guy that everybody's like oh he's awesome he's
awesome just so you know just so you're aware >> about
like the crazy stalker or whatever and from Netflix and uh >> he
was like oh this girl's such a like I've only had sex with four
people and I was like four people. You You told You told me you
weren't [__] nobody else and you had I was your second
what? I was like, "Huh?"
And so that was like kind of like one of the things where I was
like, "Okay, I'm like I mean I wasn't too hung up about that
because like I take everything with a grain of salt if someone's
like a internet personality. Like I'm not gonna like be too hung
up, but I was like, "Oh, this man's a whore." And also
uh one question I don't think it's asked but should be asked
is I actually don't remember or maybe it's been as maybe it's
been answered through some of the different posts.
But how far apart were her two meetings?
Well, actually maybe we have the date on the first one. The first
one's like March, right? And then it's the furry convention.
So hold hold on. Turkey Tom furry convention. I think the first
one was in March. So he goes from two to four.
I took I took gangsters to convention.
>> Oh, hold on. This is This is the furry convention. So
when is this? This is in September. So is it March and then September?
Was it four months apart?
So it was four months apart. Sorry, where's my math? Six months
apart. If it was six months apart or four or five months apart
and he went from two to four bodies. Oh, this man is a [__]
That can't possibly make sense, right?
Now I need to now I should figure this out. Do we have a timeline
on that on when he went to fly out like flew her out? Cuz if
it's if it's March and September and he went from two to four
bodies and she calls him a I'm just sitting here like are you
serious?
Are you serious?
What the
You're his second body and then over 5 months he two other women.
Really? That's Oh, you're a what?
>> I take everything with a grain of salt if someone's
like a internet personality. Like I'm not gonna like be too hung
up. But I was like, "Oh, this man's a
and also this man's insane cuz he's probably beating all these
women."
>> Okay, so >> all these women, dude, I have to go
back. It's It's from >> Crazy Stalker or whatever and from
>> So, she got him to watch him. Uh
he was like, "Oh, this girl's such a like I've only had sex with
four people."
>> Yeah. So he went from two
to four and he goes, "Oh, I'm like, "This girl's a I've only
had sex with four people." And she's like, "Oh, you're a actually."
>> And I was like, "Four people? You You told You told
me you weren't [__] nobody else and you had I was
your second
She, by the way, she just said like 10 minutes before this, she
said, "I'm not stupid. I didn't think he was like exclusive with
me. I'm not stupid. I didn't think he was exclusive with me."
And now she's like, "You told me we were exclusive and you had
sex with two other people." What? Dude, I'm sorry.
This Clorox Katy person is not
uh she's enjoying it too much. And I It takes me a long time
to get to the place where I'm like, she's enjoying it too much.
But she's enjoying it too much. She's enjoying it too much. Like
I don't want to hear more from her. I can be very forgiving on
a lot of this stuff that she might just really dislike this guy,
feels like betrayed by this guy and was also physically abused
during Right. That that could be true. I just don't I'm just
like done with this person as a person. I feel like this is like
a lot. She's doing a lot and she's all over the place. So >> I
was like, huh? And so that was like kind of like one of the things.
Okay. I've like I mean I wasn't too hung up about that because
like I take everything with a grain of salt if someone's like
a [__] internet personality. Like I'm not going to
like be too hung up. But I was like, "Oh, this man's a whore."
And also this man's insane cuz he's probably beating all these
women.
>> Okay, so to to rewind, you you land you're back in Portland.
This is the second time. >> This man's insane. He's probably
beating all of these women. Two more women. Two additional women.
He's probably beating all of these women. Two more women and
you don't say anything until this girl messages you a year and
a half later.
>> Oh, he's probably beating all of these >> Time
you're meeting him. >> You land
and he immediately just like like Kaia places you puts you in
a corner of his room. Is there like any anything that >> We
hang out for like we hang out for like a for like a couple hours
and then he's like, "I'm sorry, but there's hot like literally
like there's hot goths on the market. I've got to clean.
Who was it about the streams? >> Uh, it was like Minecraft
YouTubers and I guess one of them had just like gotten outed
for like touching another girl and >> And so I was there
for when Tumad died too and it was insane.
>> That was horrible.
>> So So for literally the entirety of two days, did he
not did he specifically ask that you do not like roam about the
complex? Did he like say you have to be here with me for the
sign? >> Well, like he would have he would be like, "Oh,
sit with me." And then I would be trapped in the room cuz like
you can see the door and he doesn't want people to know there's
a woman in his house. And so
>> and so he would and so I would just be like stuck in
the corner cuz I'd be there when it would start and then he would
just be streaming and then I'm just trapped. >> And he
didn't he didn't allow you to like have any presence on the stream.
So you're just in this room and you can't walk past him because
it's in front of the camera. >> No. Yeah. No. And like
Yeah. Literally
>> That's very bizarre. Like
I don't believe it. It's so bizarre. I don't believe it.
I actually don't believe it at all. Am I the only one who thinks
this is like super weird? Like I I actually don't believe this.
I don't believe Tom would say, "You have to sit in my room with
me, but you have to sit in that corner."
I think he would say, "I have to go do my stream and you can't
be on it." I believe that, but I don't believe that she's that
he would be like, "You have to sit in my you you have to sit
in the corner of my room and not ever come on camera. Like, you
have to sit in this tiny little space." That's just I think that's
obviously, dude.
Like, no. No. Probably what he said. I I feel like this is almost
certainly what he said. Oh, you might want to like sit outside
of here or maybe go do something else, but like I got a stream.
And she was like, "No, I'll just like hang out. No, I'll just
hang out."
That is way more believable. I don't Dude, it would be psychotic
for him to be like, "No, you have to sit in my room with me because
I paid to fly you here and you have to sit in that corner." I
think if he did that, she would have either one jumped out on
the stream or two like left and posted about it right
It's Yeah, this is Yeah, 100%. He was like, "Okay, if you want
to sit in the room with me, you can't come on camera." And she's
like, "That's fine. I'll sit in the corner."
because it's like you can watch the stream. You could just go
out to the other room and watch the stream if he >> There's
a there's a different person >> right? Like and also like
I don't give a about these Minecraft YouTubers. What?
why me?
>> it was he was for one even more aggressive the second
time I went and saw him and then he like barely spoke to me and
was streaming most of the time and then when he tried to speak
to me he was just like saying stupid stuff. He like and like
told me about having sex with two other girls and just was just
like insufferable. So I was having a horrible time. And I also
was convinced he had ringorm before he even had it cuz I'm looking
at his body and I see like marks and I'm like this looks like
ringorm. I'm not like this I'm don't want to touch this man.
This looks like
>> And so it here you were you gonna say >> Yeah.
I was going to ask is this the time that he got the fungal infection
>> because this was immediately after the
>> I don't I think she is she's saying that like before
he knew he had ring, >> Yes. And he told me that he thinks
he got it from the gym,
but
he like would shower after going to the gym from like at least
when I was there. And so like maybe he was doing that to keep
up appearances, but like I feel like he pro like it's it was
very weird that he got it right after going to a furry convention.
>> Yeah, it takes four to 14 days, Google says, for ringworm
to appear. So that sound right
>> about cuz I think he did the he did the furry convention
either like late February or early March and then I saw him like
around like like March 10thish or something like that.
>> Okay. So So I mean he could have been telling the truth
both times. Theoretically he could have had sex with two different
furries at the convention and gotten a ringorm.
That's my That's my working theory so far
on why that would happen. Um, okay. So, what uh so you were there,
you hang out on the first day for just a little bit and then
the hot gas reps and then you're on the mattress, I guess, based
on the layout of his room waiting for him to stop stop streaming
and then >> I'm on a little bean bag. But yeah. >> Okay.
And then um after two days of this, you ask him to fly you back
cuz you're just
>> you transmit ringorm. Um I don't know if it's like more
likely to transmit it. I would assume it's just physical contact
and obviously involves physical contact. No, he realizes that
things aren't like I'm obviously weirded out by him and I'm also
concerned that he has ringorm
and so he flies me out the day before my
>> Oh wow. Okay.
So you fly up for your birthday and you don't even get to your
birthday before you're you're being flown back. >> No.
Which honestly it was a blessing. I think I that I would have
died if I spent my birthday with him but or Yeah. Okay. So, in
between the hot gas goss uh sessions, you had with him, right?
>> Okay. And during during that, he was like violent, right?
>> Yeah. And that's kind of like when things really started
piecing together to me that I was like, "Wait, I think I am a
victim right now. Like, something's not right here."
And that's when I started like voicing my concern more to him
too it like in the bedroom and being like, "Can you not do that?"
and he kind of would just like take everything with a grain of
salt.
>> So the first time that you flew up, there was none of
this. No, no issues. It was just like vanilla. >> No, he
was still like aggressive, but like I was just like, you know,
maybe he's just like gopilled and like has only seen like BDS
and so he's like thinks that this is normal. >> But when
you say aggressive, is it just like
like I don't know a little bit forceful versus like >> No,
like still smacking and like hitting smacking and like causing
bleeding and like too rough and like cuz also he like this is
like TMI but like since he can't come you like sessions you would
be trapped with him for like an hour and also
so like no matter what you're going to end up like >> it's
just wild that the guy with the stop gooning brand has all of
the problems of like the most
human beings on earth that is just [__] up. Okay.
It's just up
>> dry at one point and then he would just like would be
trapped with him for like an hour and also so like no matter
what you're going to end up like dry at one point and then he
would just like not care and keep going. >> Did you ever
ask him like can you get lube or something? >> Yes. and
like or literally at one point we even like I made him go and
buy some and we he still never used it. He
>> Oh, that's gross. That's uh
I Dude, why? I I just don't understand why.
Like that that strikes me as ego.
That strikes me as ego that you're like, "Oh, you're not like
wet enough for me. Well, uh you I'm not putting L." It's like,
dude, I I don't know how else to like look at that. that you
think it's like an ego hit to just use lube and not make the
girl bleed and
like I
especially if you want to for like that's the thing that it's
like weird to say but if you want to have like long sessions
of having even
you should get lube cuz like people just don't straight up people
there's a limit to how much that [__] you know self
you if you especially especially if you have hours no it's not
that she wasn't it's Not even that she wouldn't have been turned
on watching you back. It's like you could have like a girl who's
turned on and like still
still have to have like lube if you're going to have like super
long sessions. Bought it to plate her and hoped she wouldn't
enforce it, I guess. So, but it's it's like one of those things
where you might as well just have it just in case, man.
Like,
but yeah, it's never had that problem. Yeah, sure. Okay. Watching
you back. Okay, sure. I just I or you've never like a girl who's
I Dude, I don't know.
It's like a pretty regular thing that if you want to have like
long
Never mind. It's just >> use the goon.
>> It's just It's like especially if she just says, "Hey,
could we get some lube? Just get lube. It's super easy. Just
go just go get lube. Just go get lube. It's so easy." >> So
you literally told him, "Use lube." And he just ignored you and
kept plowing away basically. >> Yeah. Damn near. or like
literally like try to add spit.
>> Oh, okay.
Okay. And then he would notice the blood. Like there's no way
you don't notice the blood. >> He I mean literally he would
like wipe his like dick off on a rag and it would be like like
tinged red. And he never even like batted an eye or said >> You
never even mentioned it like, "Oh, look. There's blood in this."
No.
Oh, that's Listen, that's a rough one.
That's a rough one.
Like, yeah, that sucks, man. Oh, I hope that's not true. I hope
that's not true. That's really gross.
That's really gross.
Although, hold on. Uh, there is one out for him. If she was like,
"Hey, I'm like spotting her on my period." Then maybe it makes
some sense. But I I assume she would never tell the story this
way, right? I assume she'd never tell the story this way if she
wasn't if she was on her period, the story would be really up
to tell in this way without including that. You know what I'm
saying?
>> Okay, we continue.
Um, did you ever see him use
>> I didn't, but he told me that he's done that he used
to do a lot of coke and like when I before I went to fly out
to see him the first time, he like text me one night or one day
and he was like, "Sorry, I just woke up like I did a lot of I
drank a lot and like did a lot of coke last night and he blocked
me on Instagram, but I might I might be able to see the message
at some point." But um he said that and then when I was at his
house he was talking about abusing
uh aderall that he got from Kai
from like past relationship >> and now so he still had
aderall from
>> Or the
>> cuz I guess like he had like b like cuz she had like
a she had like a
>> Okay. Um Kai is in his ex-girlfriend Kai. His ex-girlfriend
Kai. So now here's the weird thing. abusing. What does abusing
mean here? Like taking a normal dose for a taking a normal dose.
What does abusing actually mean? I don't know personally.
Is she just saying because it's not prescribed to you, it's abusing
it? Maybe.
But also, the Coke thing,
I want any statement on the Coke thing that isn't just he did
Coke with Dick Masterson once. Like, at this point, the
Does somebody have the Ry? Do you have the uh the archive of
the girl who said he loved and what she said specifically? Cuz
you could do once and say I love
and I know he did Coke with Dick Masterson. I don't know if he
does Coke all the time, but I'm I'm getting the impression that
like the Coke stuff is a little overblown personally. That's
the impression I've gotten is the Coke stuff's maybe a little
overblown.
Yeah, I know it was Dick Masterson and Bo Black he did Coke with.
I'm aware of that. I think it's just slightly overblown. Just
a little. Just a little bit. That one I just see no reason to
believe that it's like a super hardcore
I don't know important thing. Okay, hold on. We'll pull this
up. What did this girl say?
Uh, we met on Tinder. A few things I learned about Tom. He loves
his words, not mine. Now, does she say anything else about him
doing Coke? I haven't seen anything else about this guy doing
coke. Okay.
Has anyone else seen anything about this guy doing coke other
than other than there's the dick masters story which was leaked
by Bo Blacks years ago. Okay. Oh, also Veto might come on later.
I could ask him about it.
I think Veto was there actually. Although Veto might not want
to say anything. Actually, maybe I shouldn't ask Veto about it.
I feel like if Veto starts talking about doing drugs at Dick's
house, Dick is going to like cancel the show again for like the
eighth time. All right. If he finds out that Veto is on here
talking about the Coke binges at their house at at like Dick's
house, that might not go well. All right,
we'll see. We'll see. But yeah, I love Coke. It the question
would be, have you seen him doing Coke? And that's why that's
why Null just asked her, did you see him do Coke? And she said
no. >> An overstock, I guess, because he had like three
bottles at least that had her name on it.
>> Really? And he was doing this while you were there?
Yeah. >> Okay. So, timeline of this. It's he comes home
from the furry convention. You hang out for a few hours. He gets
the call from his Discord that's like, "You got you got work
to do. There's some drama." He then puts you in a bean bag and
tells you, "Don't speak or move or enter line of sight of my
camera because nobody can know I have women over at my apartment."
And then he does aderall and has sex with you for an hour cuz
he's high on aderall and it causes you to bleed. He ignores direct.
Do you see? Hold on. Do you see how he's summing this up? Do
you see the narrative? He's just driving a narrative so hard,
right? It's he's driving this narrative so hard. Oh, so he was
abusing Aderall and that's why he you for an hour. It's like
no, man. explicit instruction to do an hour.
>> In fact, I believe that is something that happens on
Coke. Isn't that on Coke? You like literally can't come. I thought
that was on I thought when you take Coke, you like literally
can't come. That's like a major thing. >> Know I have women
over at my apartment. And then he does aderall and has sex with
you for an hour cuz he's high on aderall
and it causes you to bleed. He ignores direct explicit instruction
to do things that are less painful.
And um gives you ringorm that he probably got at the furry convention.
And after 2 days of this, you're like, "Fly me back. This sucks."
>> Except I did. I never even said fly me back. I was just
like, I hope I get I go home soon. Like I don't know when he's
going to fly me home. He hasn't even brought it up. I like this
is so awkward. It's like I'm not again I was like non-verbal
and like not speaking to him low key because I was like so uncomfortable
like >> so there's like a bad vibe that was just like obvious.
>> Yeah, it was like evil vibe.
>> Okay, maybe
non-verbal is a term. Non-verbal is a weird term. Yeah, it's
usually when you were being um like abused in some way. It's
not just a term. It's like an abuse term as well. But yeah, you're
non-verbal. You are like traumatized. It's a trauma term. You're
traumatized. You go non-verbal. I think he could kind of pick
up on that. So then he sent me
>> Yeah, it's it's really obvious when there's like static
and you're like the only two people in like a room and it's just
like terrible static, you know, >> trapped in an apartment
that's in a
>> Yeah, something like that. So,
let's see. Was there was there anything else? You said that you
both said that he non-consensually began to record you guys having
sex. Was this both times that you saw him? Yeah. Every sing lit
literally every single time we had sex, he recorded it and I
and he never asked. Literally just one time I like looked back
and I was like, "Oh, that's a phone." And then one >> okay,
actually something null should be asking here and act he should
be asking this. How many times did you guys have cuz she says
every time and I'm like, well, what are the numbers? Cuz if you
get past like 5 to 10, that becomes incredibly like compelling.
But if you had twice in the like 3 or 4 days you're with him,
then it doesn't actually matter as much. Like sorry, it still
matters a lot. But to say like you're saying every time is in
he has to record every encounter.
Sorry, it still matters. I'm not saying it doesn't matter even
if he only does it twice. But I do think that if you had like
a lot and he did it every single time like 10 plus times then
that's like oh that's a pattern. He has to do it.
What Chase do is saying is consent doesn't matter. No, I was
saying like they're they're really different things. And in terms
of like when you're saying he did it every single time, he did
it every single time 10 times. That's way different than every
single time two
>> he the only time he ever came was this is like this
is so funny, but the only time he ever came was um we had and
then he proceeds to be like, "Wait, I need to come." gets me
like gets gets off me and then just literally in front like damn
near on top of me in front of me. I'm like trapped under him
still. He starts watching the video he just recorded and and
I was like what the is happening? That was like also
>> am I the only one who I'm I'm sitting here I'm like
dude I'd be too embarrassed to do this in front of somebody like
like the first time you meet them or the second time like the
first time you meet them you're just like dude I can't come.
I'm going to like I'm going to just drink off. I'm just going
to jump off. I feel like I just take the hit. Am I wrong? Feel
like I just take the hit and not come. It's not what I'm saying
either, literally gamer, but thank you. No, I just take the hit
and not come, dude. Like, you need your you need your not that
badly. >> Kind of an awakening,
man. >> The I was like, "Oh, he's got like he's got death
grip. What is happening?" >> So, this is like the second
day of the second meet up. He's like, "This ain't working. I
gotta I gotta watch my own masterpiece here that I just that
I literally just recorded. >> Literally like literally
had like Yeah, just recorded like moments ago.
>> Okay. Wow. Um
were you the one that said if you flexed in the mirror after
I would I would shoot myself. Is >> No, that was her. But
he did that with me too. And also the like I noticed when we
would have he had a mirror in his room and it literally >> Did
he literally do the Patrick Baitman thing? I was going to say
like literally that's why I call him a Patrick Baitman type gooner
cuz for one he's like psychotic low key and he did that [__]
and I swear he like he must like live by how Patrick Baitman
lives lowkey cuz like I watched him do that and I was like oh
this isn't normal like this something's wrong.
I mean would you say that he's like actually trying to replicate
the scene like it's just the exact same thing? I I mean damn
near like I don't want to like put the like say like that he
like is literally replicating the scene but it I just like it
literally felt like that. I like looked up saw he was looking
in the mirror just staring at himself like
>> Okay. Do we not have the scene with him flexing here?
Do we not have that with Tom face swapped onto it? Do we not
have that yet? Be real. Be real. We've got to have that some
somebody did that already, right? I swear it would have taken
somebody like two minutes to do it today. Somebody's made it.
If you've seen it on Twitter, send it to me because I do want
to pull it up. Okay, thank you very much. We'll continue. >> I
think it's muscle. >> And this was like not discussed at
all. Like there was >> this is this is like the part where
I'm like, "Yeah, you guys are going to just like gig chat at
Tom." that like
that he like had the mirror and he's literally flexing into the
mirror like looking how good he looks while he
that's you know >> no two-way conversation about or or
>> No, we never had any conversation really about like
kinks or like what we were into like other than like bare minimums
of like
>> of like Yeah. I I like
I don't Yeah, I don't even we never even had like any bare minimum
talking about sex. They're just like, "Do you want to have Okay."
>> I do wonder a little bit like is Tom just a victim of
like
is he just really
Just like, "Oh, I'll stick to like scene girls. I'll stick to
like seen gothy girls and they all they they were all like his
kids cuz that's why they're goth and so like I get to rap them
now." Is that is that like in his mind the amount of calculus
he's doing? is like these girls are all like super traumatized.
They're super up so I can just do whatever I want. Like I actually
don't know. But to me it's like I have no idea how you go into
a encounter and you start slapping a girl with like no buildup
and no pre like discussed consent. Like I I would never ever
ever
Hold on. You guys say Destiny taught him well on the slapping
thing. I don't think Destiny would go into a like thing and slap
somebody. That's that's literally like how you get reported.
That's how you get cancelled is you go into like a
dynamic so you go into a relationship and you just start slapping
somebody without discussing it first. That's like doing that
in the middle of with somebody that you never discussed it. That's
literally how you actually get me to or whatever, right? It's
but justifiably so. Oh, I see what you're saying that you target
girls who you think can't like accuse you of something. Man,
it's tough for me to say that like a 20-year-old could really
do that unless it's just straight up emulating.
You know what I'm saying, dude. I think it might be worth it
to go back on um
I don't know if Riyle's got like the video uploads from a long
time ago, some of the Turkey Tom appearances. He made he made
comments about girls
that were like, dude, he he had some like negative thoughts from
the Destiny community
Like I want to say that he was like
BPD girls and like girls who wore like chokers and on this stream
in like a pretty serious way while simultaneously hooking up
with these girls. Like there there might have been some element
there of like he just didn't like women who were like this and
he was like actually
like vicariously carrying out his revenge on Kai through them.
I don't know. There might be some weird thing going on there.
Okay. It's very very very possible.
>> Okay. And the few times you would say anything about
like that's too far. It was just like completely not like did
he react at all? Did he say anything? Was it just like >> not
really? He would be like he'd be like my bad. Maybe like fix
how he's acting for like two seconds and then do it again.
>> Not good, man.
>> Okay. I can't think of anything else. Did Is there anything
else memorable that you remember from the second >> Not
much. He was texting me during the when I met like during the
second meeting. I also noticed that when we were watching you
I like people >> Yeah. And people may not be aware Meowin
is is a woman that he met at a he met in real life and she's
like a 247 larper of like a dog. >> Yeah. Like a puppy
girl.
>> Are you going to use Filmont? I'm not going to go look
for that right now. Um I'd probably have to go to my old Rumble
archives and I'm not going to do that right now. I was suspect
of her just cuz I mean she looked like only fans type. So I was
like h and she was also a dog.
>> When you say only fans type you're referring to like
the blush and the makeup that kind of >> I guess you know
and like it's like you know like that. Yeah I guess. And like
eirl type like that.
>> Okay. Okay sense. Um, do you mind if I show the picture
of because after you flew back, you got the like the ringorm
was like visible. Do you like mind if I show that? >> Yeah.
Yeah, that's fine. >> Okay. So, how
how long >> that one photo Oh, sorry. You go first. >> No,
I was just going to ask how long after um you flew back did it
did it show up >> within like a week. Like I think like
>> within 4 to 14 days. Is that fair? >> Yeah, within
4 to 14 days. Yeah, it was like within like like five days
cuz I was like fine on my birthday and then a couple days after
that like lit cuz there's a picture of the bruise on my face
and right under it is what it is is ringorm. Luckily that's the
only little spot I ever got since I went
>> dude I don't know anything about ringorm so I don't
know is it is it like bad null sounds mad chill for real? No,
he doesn't. Matt null at different points here kind of sounds
like he's gripping it for real. All right, that's what he sounds
like. It sounds like he's gripping it through multiple segments
of this stream. I feel like he's consistently driving in like
a weird direction. What's up, lav? How's it
>> Hi. Ringworm is a fungus.
>> I know ringorm is a fungus. I know it's a fungal infection.
I just didn't know like I don't know how bad it is. It feels
like it's pretty treatable. I don't even know what the downside
of getting it. extremely treatable. It's just highly contagious.
Yeah. Well, this this this woman got ringorm. Are you familiar
with what's going on here that we're watching uh Turkey Tom's
former flings kind of reporting him to null apparently the owner
of Kiwi Farms.
>> Oh, I didn't know that. But I know a little bit about
it because we talked about it yesterday.
>> Like when I left, he was like, "Bye. I'll see you again."
Blah blah blah. Like good to see you. sorry I was so busy and
I was like >> yeah okay I'm not gonna see you again.
>> Okay. And then that was
in 2024
or five. >> Yeah 24.
uh did you have any encounter with him after that? >> We
still followed each other on Instagram for like a year and I
didn't want to be the first one to unfollow him. So I would just
kind of and he like didn't post like that. So I would never see
anything of his. So I was just kind of like waiting for him to
unfollow me cuz it was weird cuz we like cut like kind of like
I just told him I like didn't think it was going to work and
I kind of thought it was like weird and it just wasn't really
with what was happening.
And he was like okay cool. And so we like stopped talking and
it was like whatever. And but and he would like like memes I
post periodically or like a random photo like maybe like three
times after we talked, but like otherwise we didn't really like
talk too
>> Okay. So then that is March 2024.
>> I mean she's not accusing him of right pretty obviously.
Listmaniac
that's like obviously not what the accusation is. I don't know
if Do you think that's the accusation or you just memeing? Maybe
you're just >> When did Sacramento? When did you meet
>> I met him May 10th of 2025.
>> May 10th. So more than a full year later. And and you
met him on Tinder,
>> Uh yes. >> Okay. Um, right off the bat, real quick,
one of the things that a lot of people who are on his side, like
in the YouTube sphere, said is that you had a screenshot of you
matching with Tom.
Wait, Kickbot is down. What?
Hold on. Maybe Kickbot's not down.
Kickbot sometimes just [__] up, dude. It's really
annoying. Oh, well, it's it is taking a second here.
>> You said that was strange cuz in your >> Wait,
what the [__]
I didn't notice yesterday I had a $40 donation. Somebody gave
$40 for the golem donation. I thought it was a $5 donation. Holy.
I probably should add another house. >> But you did not
know him before you met up, but you took a picture of the match.
Is there is there a reason for that?
>> Um, yeah. I took a picture of the match because I could
kind of tell there was like something weird about this guy. Like
I didn't know if he was famous or whatever. And also I did that
to other people as well on Tinder.
>> Just you. Wait, what? >> Something weird.
>> Hold on. This is asking why she screenshotted. So we're
on to Sacramento now. And he's asking why we screenshotted the
match. >> Took a picture of the match. Is there is there
a reason for that?
>> Um, yeah. I took a picture of the match because I could
kind of tell there was like something weird about this guy. Like
I didn't know if he was famous or whatever. And also,
>> wait, what?
I took a picture cuz there was something weird about him. I didn't
know if he was famous or whatever.
I'm confused.
I I
maybe there's a better explanation after this, but that sounds
>> I did that to other people as well on
>> Dr. Phil just tipped $5. He promised her the pineapple
in his would provide the vitamin C, but checkmate,
>> but then he never came. Scurvy Risk right there. Checkmate.
I don't know why that cut off. God, Kickbot's Kickbot's kind
of falling behind recently. I don't know what Kickbot's doing,
but thank you very much for the donation. Second, I really appreciate
it, buddy. >> He messed with to like gossip with uh like
like girlfriends. >> Yeah, like a couple of them. But yeah,
he seemed like kind of weird, so I took Yeah, I took pictures
of our match. >> What What about his like bio was like,
"Oh, I got to I got to document this in case I go missing or
something like what's notice weird." Um, he was like covering
his face a lot in the pictures
>> like maybe I believe that made her go, "Oh, like I'm
going to swipe on this guy cuz he's like kind of goofy, funny,
and then but he's covering his face, so like I'm going to swipe,
but I'm going to take a picture of him." >> There was like
there was something really off about him. So, yeah.
>> Um, and then I can kind of clarify on our first date,
he did. I obviously figured out who he was really quick, but
he continued to lie to me about what he did for a living. And
yeah, >> what did he say?
>> He told me he did like video editing or like videography.
>> Okay. So,
what when you interacted with him, I remember I saw some screenshots
of your text messages and if I remember correctly, he said something
literally to the effect of don't look up who I am or something.
>> Was that before or after you got weirded weirded out
by him and asked questions?
>> That was like during when I started asking questions
about him because I started getting really suspicious. Um, especially
after the whole Ellie thing happened. Um, because he he was still
following bunch of eirls who like
>> Okay, seems like no wants Kiwi Farms to be the Wikileaks
of weird perverts and celebrity gossip. I'm surprised he hasn't
been putting out bounties on stories. So,
I think there I liked Private Huff's explanation here. I hadn't
thought about this, but this could be a thing. Turkey Tom's thread
hates him
because Turkey Tom profits from Kiwi Farms threads. Except unlike
some other people who do reference Kiwi Farms and source Kiwi
Farms, there's a thing where Kiwi Farms really hates it if you
don't source people, right? If you don't source Kiwi Farms, if
you just use Kiwi Farms info and never source them, they very
much hate that. Okay? And Turkey Tom is the most prolific, most
successful person who constantly sources kiwi farms and constantly
refuses to source them correctly. Right? So he will use them
as a source and he will never say he's using them as a source.
And I think that upsets them really badly. And it's possible
that that really off null that Turkey he feels like Turkey Tom
should be their number one like advertising outlet and he and
Turkey Tom never references them, right? His videos are literally
Yeah, I know. I know that it's that his videos are literally
reading summaries of Kiwi Farms threads. I know that. I'm saying
that that could be why Null is just driving this narrative against
him like trying to [__] them over so badly is because
like null is actually really
that or maybe he does he doesn't cite them as a source is maybe
what I should be saying. But um Null might be really pissed about
that that like hey you use information from my website all of
the time and you refuse to ever site your source here.
Yeah, and Turkey Tom was on calls with Null, being really cool
with Null. I wonder where if there was a fallout. Well, I would
imagine
I don't know what the fallout would be. I I would imagine it'd
be like disassociating or possibly like negative press he'd given
towards Kiwi Farms at some point. But yes, I do know that Tom's
videos are just reading Kiwi Farms threads. I'm aware. >> I
kind of
figured out that he had slept with before and I was getting more
sus. And so I ended up looking him up and I told him like, "Hey,
I looked you up and I found some weird [__] about
you." like just giving him a chance to explain it himself, but
instead of explaining himself, he ended up just getting really
mad at me for even looking.
>> Okay. So,
um you were just you Why did you match him then if he felt he
was so weird?
>> Um cuz he he had big muscles and like I could tell that
like
he was I was he also did hide his face. I mean, if we're being
honest, he's not the most like facially gifted person, but yeah.
>> bro, you slept with him. That's [__] up,
man. >> It like piqu your interest. Like, I have to know
what this guy looks like if he's like a zero out of 10 troglodite
or like really handsome but shy. Is that Is that the gist? >> Yeah,
I guess so. And I did figure out who he was like very quickly
after matching. So, >> okay. So, I guess after you guys
matched, how long was it before you're like, I have to figure
out this guy's dating history. Let me check his >> It was
during when the whole Ellie scenario started happening when I
started getting suspicious.
Um, and I I looked through everything and he had told me that
he had like flown out some girls before. So, I was I started
being like, hm, this is very interesting. And I started looking
in his following and I found all these like e girls. I I actually
saw Katie and I I even asked him about Katie and he was like,
"Oh, that was just like some girl that I dated or whatever."
>> But so he's trying to to hide his identity. Sorry. Were
you guys like near each other or was this in a long distance
thing? Cuz he's in Maine, but you're in in Texas, right? Actually,
so to clarify that, he moved to Texas about a week before we
matched on Tinder
and he's still in Texas right now. >> Okay, so he moved.
>> That's a big thing. Um, people were saying, "Oh, like
they don't live near near each other." They're like freaking
out. It's like, "Oh, no, he moved to Texas. She's from Texas.
Easy."
>> Also, the Sacramento thing must be a misleader or a
must mis mislead. Yeah. So, they she's in Texas. long move from
Maine to Texas and then is is like, "Okay, I got to get into
the the Tinder scene right away. I got to establish roots here.
>> Meet you." And then if he's trying to hide his career
and
like
is it weird to hop on Dude, why would why would it be weird for
a 20-year-old
to hop on Tinder when they move to a new area? 22year-old.
That's the least weird thing I've ever heard in my entire life.
That's like so disconnected from
Oh, I guess he just he really needed to hop into the Tinder scene
there. I guess put down roots. Yeah, you're saying that like
he's a weirdo for doing No, that's like totally normal.
What the else do you think he's going to do? >> His identity.
Why did he like add you on social media from his like Turkey
>> Um, that was after I figured out who he was. I figured
out who he was like maybe like a like as like during our first
date. So, >> yeah. How?
>> Um because I This is kind of a funny story, but he was
living in like a literal mansion. And so I
I pulled up and I was like, "What the hell?" And I kind of was
like really suspicious about him. And then I saw that he had
like a bunch of Turkey Tom like merchandise everywhere and I
was like, "Okay, well,
>> is that implying that their first date is at his house?
You just go over to his house for a first date? I I would believe
that she didn't know who he was. Some of this stuff could all
make sense, but she's she doesn't know. This guy hides his face
in all of his Tinder
profile pictures or most of them. And then you just go over to
his house
and it's like, "Oh, well, this guy's in a
I She recognized the merch. Well, I'm guessing that could make
sense that you walked into this place.
You see some that says like Turkey Tom on it. >> One question
I would have liked Mel to ask here is oh were you aware of Turkey
Tom as an internet creator before meeting him in real life? Like
did you know of the the creator named Turkey Tom? Do you know
about that?
>> It's like I know who you are.
>> She found the Turkey Tom plush box in the closet and
looked him up. >> Is that what it was? He's like a box
$5
this him and called him ugly in a for eirls. Doesn't that just
reflect on her standards and call her an eirls? >> Yeah,
I mean a little bit.
Yeah, she I mean she kind of is an egirl. The Clorox Katy one
a little bit of an e-irl. Maybe like alt or something. Not really
egirl aesthetic, but more or less an eirl. Yeah, women do like
this because they see enough muscles on an arm. On the arm. Dude,
Turkey Tom was not that ripped. Okay, I'm I'm going to say it.
At whatever point they met, like early 2024, he was like getting
a little better. He was not like jacked. His arms weren't massive.
They looked massive cuz he didn't do leg day, but like they weren't
that they weren't that crazy. I think he was benching. I don't
think he could bench two plates. I'm pretty confident he couldn't
even bench two plates at that >> Pencil plushies.
Uh yeah, he well he had like turkey stickers and like various
like stop gooning and all of his like merch. His his room was
such a mess he would just have like [__] thrown about.
So that's how I kind of saw everything. >> I wish I had
a a full picture I could share of this. Don't try to do it cuz
you might mess up the call. But your um avatar on Discord is
just a picture of you with like your hat pulled down and the
hat is the
>> Jesus Christ. standards have gotten high to be like
jacked to be like to have huge arms usually or a at least a huge
chest you usually think like two plates pretty normal. Technically,
your arms aren't going to they they don't have to be that big
to bench, but like they're going to be bigger
Nobody gives a streamers especially don't care. No streamer is
going to go to another streamer and say, "Hey, I heard you banned
this chatter. That's really dumb of you."
If I wanted to make fun of Queenman, I'd talk about the fact
that he's a 4'11 hobbit. Okay? That he's like a mix of Bilbo
and he's Bilbo and Legololis at the same time. Okay? That's how
I make fun of Queenman. Why the would I bring up that he banned
a chatter? That's what >> I think that's how it came up.
>> That's That's so funny that you're just like normie
searching like, "Okay, does Turkey Tom cheat?" And there's just
like this forum thread about it because of of of Kai.
Um Okay. So, you told him on the first date that that you had
already figured out who he is and he didn't just like immediately
cut tips $15.
How dare you soaks? How dare you come here after getting banned?
How dare you? No one is too small to make a difference. >> You
can end your shame.
>> Thank you very much for the Greta Thmberg donation.
With that said, another hour on the stream. Let's go.
Big kickbot donations today. Let's go. >> Thank you very
much. >> No, he he continued to talk to me. me. I mean,
obviously we dated for like 7 months after that. So, yeah, he
knew that I knew who he was at that point, but like I wasn't
like
really researching. I like I mean I looked at what his channel
was and I was like, "Oh, okay." He does like documentaries, like
whatever, but I didn't really look into him that hard until later.
>> Um, cope, cope, cope. Obvious lie. Obvious lie. Cope.
I don't I haven't seen if she said it yet. I might have missed
it at some point. She says she was kind of with Tom for the bag.
Okay. Sorry if I'm spoiling something that comes later, but she
just said I didn't really look into who he was. Like I didn't
look that closely. I just knew he did internet documentaries
or something. Bro, if you were in this for the bag, if you saw
that he was rich and that like kind of swayed you, you definitely
looked pretty heavily into what he was doing, right?
You wouldn't just go, "Oh, this guy's rich. I I don't really
care what he does." No, you'd be watching that every night. Count
your Benjamins.
Don't cope and say, "Oh, well, I just I took a a little look.
I didn't really look that much." >> Did he seem worried
that you knew? >> I think so. I think that he was more
worried after the fact.
Um, when I started looking into him, that's when he started freaking
out at me. >> Okay. And how how long was that until the
relationship? >> I started getting sus maybe like 4 months
into it. Um because that kind of
>> sorry when you say sus what was it that was like okay
I have to do more research now I know who he is but I have to
like figure out like his history
>> because I at that point I had seen um I figured out
who the girl he was texting was was like this like really weird
girl who dressed like a kid and so I was like okay this is like
very alarming I need to go and research him immediately. Oh >> And
he was
>> I
just straight up don't I still don't believe her. I still don't
believe her. I feel like she looked it up. She was totally fine
with all of it. She didn't think the content was weird. And then
maybe maybe she did start finding out it becomes pretty obvious
that she became convinced he was cheating. She became convinced
that he was like a piece of and cheating on her and she started
messaging a bunch of people about like I think I think
and there isn't evidence of this directly that she went through
his follow list and just DM'd a people I guarantee if you go
through some of the e girls Tom follows. If you were to do this,
if you were to be interested in this story and you go look at
Tom's follow list on Instagram or some, you go find some of the
e girls and you say, "Hey, do you have a message from like a
girl saying, "Hey, uh, have you talked to this guy?" Cuz that's
how she talked to that's how she found Katie. That's how she
started talking to Katie. Okay. She actually like went through
and messaged Katie as one of the people he was talking to and
was like, "Hey, have you talked to Turkey Tom before?"
I truly believe What is this? You said this should be background
music. Okay.
Nah. Although funny. Let it land for a
>> Now, I ain't saying she a gold [__]
>> but she ain't messing with no broke [__]
>> Okay. All right. Yeah, we could have done that, but
we're not going to. Okay. Funny. Funny. But no.
Anyway, I I think she got really jealous and was like the kind
of girl she she keeps saying, "I'm a normal kind of girl. I'm
a normal kind of girl."
I would take if somebody gave me like even odds, I would bet
that there's
minimum 50 DMs that went out to women saying, "Hey, have you
talked to Turkey Tom before?" "Hey, have you talked to Turkey
Tom before? Hey, have you talked to Turkey Tom before?" "Hey,
have you talked to Turkey Tom before?" "Hey, have you talked
to Turkey Tom before?" I think that's happened
nigh on a hundred times and I have no evidence for that. It's
a total soul read. I've got nothing else except this
>> Was just did you like see this on his computer? Was
he like on his phone with this per like looking at her Instagram
a lot or >> he was he was texting her and I saw like her
her >> Oh, I had not seen this picture. That's a new picture.
Dude, at what point at what point do you just say, "Bro, you
know you could just pay for prostitutes, right?
Like I
I hate to be vulgar here, Tom, you just pay for prostitutes and
then they're like attractive and like around you. You just you
could literally just pay for actual prostit
right? Look at how pleased he is with himself.
Dude, it's just for me. I'm sitting here and I'm
"Bro, you're a millionaire. You're like a 20-year-old millionaire.
Get a haircut.
Get a haircut
and then get like a hot [__] What the hell, man?"
name and her contact photo uh matched like what she looked like
on Instagram.
>> Okay. And if if I remember correctly, this is Ellie,
who is like an >> Well, I'm I'm sorry. I I don't mean to
be that judgmental, but this girl's not attractive. This girl's
like not hot.
Like, I'm sorry. If you think Clavvicular gets the he does cuz
he's looks maxing, you're okay. It's cuz he's wallet maxing.
All right. And Tom's wallet maxing at that age
there. Okay. Here's a better example. I live in Canada.
Some of the ugliest I've ever seen who are good at hockey pull
absolute rockets. Okay?
Absolute 11 out of 10. Bro, you could be ugly as if you're good
at hockey, you pull the hottest women in Canada. Just a rule.
It's a fact of life. Okay? It's a fact of life. You're great
hockey player. And I mean there's some other things that go along
with that because um obviously you're usually in shape if you're
a good hockey player, right?
But there are some some straight up like
like they would be working in a Bulgarian circus if they weren't
good at hockey. Okay. And you know Tom
Tom not that far a Canadian. No, Canadians are Canadian girls
are hot. Sorry King Gedra. Nice try. player on Instagram and
she since like dyed her hair red and >> oh hold on I'll
roll it back just so we don't lose contact >> and her contact
photo uh texting >> on his phone with this per like looking
at her Instagram a lot or >> he was he was texting her
and I saw like
>> explain that explain what the you just said Bulgarian
circus like somebody who's got a face for radio >> like
her her name and her contact photo uh match like what she looked
like on
>> Okay. And if if I remember correctly, this is Ellie
who is like an age player on Instagram
and she since like dyed her hair red and looks a lot like or
tries to like dress up like Kai. Is that right? I I think I have
a picture of her on the stream, but I I don't >> I'm trying
to
make sure I got this
I'm not sure if she dresses like Kai, but she definitely likes
to dress like a kid. And I saw some people on Kiwi Farms posting
that she's been exposed for publicly being a lollycon and doing
age play. So, I'm really like not surprised.
>> Is this the Ellie girl, too? I find it wild that this
girl is the same as this girl. These are the same girl.
Like this girl who's like the Wendy's logo and this girl are
the same girl.
That's the same girl. Like I'm sorry. What filter? What? I don't
even know about filters. It just doesn't look the
>> Yeah, this is the Finding Nemo. No, this isn't the Finding
Nemo cosplay. There is a Finding Nemo cosplay she does with the
>> Mollycon and doing age play. So, I'm really like not
surprised based on everything I've seen.
Okay. So, you just saw saw him creeping on her Instagram or was
he like talking to her? >> He was texting her. >> Okay.
He was doing this a lot to the point where you could like catch
him out on it multiple times.
>> And when you caught him out and this was four months
in, right?
>> Yeah. I saw the Starbucks thing. That's why I'm saying
it's not a that's why it's not a Finding Nemo cosplay.
>> Okay. I think. >> And when you you caught him
out on this, what was his explanation?
>> Oh, he would he would say so much. He was like, "Oh,
well, I was h or she was hacked and my nudes are getting leaked.
Like, I just I have to talk to her. Like, I wouldn't I like I
wouldn't talk to her if I didn't have to." And I was like, "Okay,
>> okay." But this was when he explained, >> "Bro,
this one is just particular. It's like like I get it.
I'm sorry. Tom is independently wealthy at this age. That makes
a difference. That does make it. Maybe it shouldn't.
>> And that um he was being likeed,
right? >> Yes. And so I >> She looks all right. She's
not like ugly, dude. No, not my preference, man. Not my I'm sorry.
I I can be like I understand how she could be somebody's preference.
Not my preference. Okay. He kind of gave him the benefit of the
doubt and I was like, "Okay, well maybe he is just talking to
her a bunch because, you know, he's being hacked and like he's
scared." But
>> okay, so just to clarify, cuz I I didn't explain too
well, but when you caught him out on this, he explained to you
in text messages that he had previously, before your relationship
been sending her nudes and she had been hacked and both of their
nudes were leaked. And the extortionist was sending um pictures
of his to his family and threatening him to post it online unless
he gave him money.
>> Yeah. That's exactly what happened. >> And so
his his explanation for why he was texting her during your relationship
in your presence, like right next to you, was that he has to
sort out what to do with Ellie cuz she's involved.
I think it's crazy that he he does he does present it this way.
Like, yeah, I have to I have to text her and then he kepts he
keeps texting her after.
And
I think it's just crazy that he lied. That's probably the most
damning evidence against him, right? That when he's being accused
of being into this stuff, he goes, "No, I'm not into that stuff.
This girl weirded me out. I couldn't even be around her." And
then I like I had to leave. And then you get all these pictures
of him hanging out with her with like hanging out with her in
person, holding her up. She's in multiple different outfits,
so they hung out for multiple days. Like, I get why you lied,
but you transparently lied. Like, it's not even close that you
were you weren't even remotely telling the truth. You were just
obviously lying.
>> Okay. Um, did that ever resolve or did you continue
to like catch her talking to or catch him talking to her throughout
like the remainder of the
Um he ended up telling me that she like reached out to him again
but and was trying to I guess kind of rekindled things with him
but he told her that he has a girlfriend and to stop talking
to him but that was like months after the original incident.
So that's why I was like what?
>> Oh hold on. >> I guess kind of reach her >> throughout
like the remainder of the relationship.
Um he ended up telling me that she like reached out to him again
but and was trying to I guess kind of rekindled things with him
but he told her that he has a girlfriend and just >> What
do you mean rekindle? Doesn't that fly in the face of what she
said earlier a little bit? I wonder if her story is not a little
if if Tom got weirded out and just left without ever hanging
out with her and he told you that. What the would there be to
rekindle?
Wow. >> Stop talking to him. But that was like months after
the original incident. So that's why I was like, "What?" >> Okay.
Okay. Um, how often did you did you see him like overall? Like
did you just see him like once a week throughout the entire relationship?
>> Yeah, pretty much. cuz I'm in college and we we're like
medium distance. He lives like an hour and a half away from me.
So
>> Okay. And that never changed. You never like moved in
together or anything?
>> Okay. Did anything before?
>> Uh yeah, this girl was 100% getting cheated on. 100%
this girl was getting cheated on.
Bro, why if Tom's like actually some kind of gooner? Well, hold
on. Wait, maybe not. No, I Man, it's rough because it seems like
there is something here that sort of leads me to believe maybe
he was getting off of the eirl. Maybe he's like trying to build
something more consistent, right?
Cuz he did take this girl to meet his
But I'm just sitting here and I'm like, dude, Tom's not really
on the internet at all. He basically only publishes main channel
videos now.
So, what was he doing with all of his time, right? And this girl
lives an hour and a half away. Now, I've got like this huge gap
in time. Tom used to stream all the time. He used to make videos
all the time.
Where
Where was he? What was he doing?
I feel like I don't know what this guy was doing. I feel like
this girl is getting cheated on. That's my calculus here. Okay.
>> Where you caught him texting Ellie in those first four
months cuz you were with him for seven months in total, right?
So like four before, three after.
>> In the first four months, was there anything like strange
or weird or like red flag?
Um, well, that's when he bought me the Hello Kitty merchandise,
and he would he would talk about how his ex-girlfriend Kai kind
of like ruined his perception of love and he doesn't know if
he'll ever be able to love anyone again. And also just told her
that told me that the um the relationship was terrible.
And um the first few times we had been together, he never hit
me, but the hitting did start pretty
>> dude. Uh we're we're going to get Okay, we're going
to get We're going to keep having this repeat over and over and
over again
that Kai [__] this guy's life up. Kai [__]
him up. All right.
Jeez, she really did a number on him. soon into our relationship
and he never asked me if that I was okay with it or
like asked me for permission. He would just start hitting me.
>> that's going to be that's that's a tough one, man. That's
a tough one right
That's going to be I think one of the
I think that's going to be one of the bigger allegations comes
out of this is they both sort of elaborate and say yes there
was no consent beforehand. He just sort of she clarified that
in the KF post. I don't know if she clarified it but it is is
good getting it like on the record clear as day that they're
both accusing him of going to like hitting like in the faceish
like right off the bat like that's just where he went >> So
okay there's two things there. Um, Katie, real quick, when you
were talking to him, would he ever bring up Kai? Like, for no
reason. Just start talking >> He told me I looked like
Kai. He asked me if I like Monster High dolls because of Kai
and said like, "Oh, well, my ex-girlfriend liked them." >> Oh
my god. >> And like, and then again, like I went through
I went through his closet and he had like an entire like >> Oh,
Jesus Christ, man. Um, I think no follows follows up on the hitting
later,
Man, the this is the age play stuff and
that's rough. I thought she said I thought she said the opposite
before,
right? This is Sacramento. I thought Sacramento had said
that
um there's lots of stuff you missed dirty as you'd have to go
back and watch. I thought he I thought she said explicitly that
Tom never tried to force her to dress like Kai and didn't want
her to look like Kai.
This is Katie. Oh, is it Are we back to Katie now? Cuz we were
on to Sacramento for a while. We're talking about Sacramento
now. Like Sacramento living there, dating him. This has been
Sacramento for a while. >> Like like at least like six
items that were all like girl shirts from Hot Topic of like Invader
Zim and like that. And I was like, "What the [__]
are these?" And he was like, "Those are my ex." >> Maybe.
Did Katie just cut in?
like I know who you are.
>> Yeah, sorry. That is Katie. My bad. That's Katie. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. >> The are these? And he was like, "Those
are my ex-girlfriends. I just haven't gotten rid of them." >> And
then Rowan said that he still had that when he moved.
>> Wait, he just kept her close. That's a little bit weird.
>> Yeah. So, like he brought her up multiple times though,
especially to me cuz I like I talked to him right after they
broke up and like it was and he told Yeah. again. He told me
I looked like her, like everything and like told me multiple
times like, "Oh, you remind me of Kai." >> He told me multiple
times that you looked like his ex.
>> And that you acted like his ex. >> Yes. Even though
we like he would ask me if I was into things and it was obvious
that he was asking because Kai would like them. And then he would
get like a little sad when he when I would be like,
This is all again this is like narrativization from a girl who
really doesn't like him to me.
Like I just I don't think I really don't think that's how it
was man
that he's explicitly like oh you weren't into this and then are
you into Hello Kitty? No. A
like come on I Tom's like a weirdo. Is he that much of a weirdo?
Is he that much of a total weirdo? I feel like these stories
are a little far. The the Katie stories seem a little far for
me. Like they're pushing
they're pushing pretty far beyond what I would expect.
That's that's that's what a stupid thing to say to a woman. Did
Did Sacramento did you hear anything like that? Did he ever compare
you to Kai?
Um he would be he basically said that
um like my parents would love you because you're nothing like
Kai.
And he kind of would like ask me questions to see if >> Dude,
dude, hold on. Oh my goodness. Kai getting roasted. Kai getting
absolutely roasted out here.
>> Oh, my parents would love you. You're nothing like my
psychotic ex. My parents would love you. You're nothing like
that. Psycho B. Kai getting roasted. Kai comes out, puts out
a document, kind of poo pooing some of these things a little
bit. By the way describe the document is totally too. But
Kai poo poos it a little bit. Kai's like trying to, you know,
help Tom out. Tom in the background. Oh my my ex was a total
psycho who ruined me forever. And and my parents would love you
cuz you're nothing like her. We had similar hobbies, but he was
basically
basically I was referred to as his first quote unquote normal
girlfriend that didn't have BPD. So, >> okay. Did you ever
feel like
he was like training himself? Like, okay, I'm going
>> um This girl absolutely just read Kiwi Farms a whole
bunch.
I'm telling you, this girl just read Kiwi Farms a whole bunch.
Dude, girls don't talk like this. I'm sorry. That's like that's
like Kiwi Farm's pickme language right there. Like it's it's
actually embarrassing how obvious it is right there, right? I
noticed this with both of them that they just want to be like
their total pickmies for that KF thread. And that's never going
to work out well for you. Okay? They're never going to like you.
They're never going to like you. Doesn't matter what you do.
Don't try to Don't try to, you know, strain and stretch for their
approval because they're never going to like you. They're always
going to think you're a [__] weirdo. They're always
going to think you're a
okay? Is you are not a stupid for as long as you're feeding them
juicy details about Tom's personal life. The second you run out
of juicy details about Tom's personal life, you're a [__]
again. Okay. Instantly like a pumpkin at midnight.
Yeah. Like turning back into a pumpkin at mid midnight. >> Going
to have like a normal relationship now. I try to Oh my gosh.
It It really felt like that >> all the time. >> Brain,
Discord or ban? Right now, you disagree with the take. Discord
or ban? Actually, the way this works is you are timed out one
day, you get in the Discord. Oh, wait. You're banned from the
Discord, too. Unlucky for Verra. Vain is also banned from the
Discord. I guess you're just out for a day. Good >> Yeah,
all the time. I felt like he was so used to like BPD. >> Oh,
I I actually feel bad about that. If he can't hop on the Discord,
I probably not going to keep him timed out. He is. I'm I'm also
not unbanning him from the Discord. [__] that >> I
guess I'm normal and he didn't really know how to like act because
I wasn't constantly being like, "I love you so much. Like, I
want to spend the rest of my day my days with you." Like, I wasn't
kind of doing the BPD behaviors. And so, I think he was like,
"Oh, >> I What a weird reductionist way of looking at that.
I It's so bizarre to me. Brain's out. Brain's free." Um, that's
just like a weird reductionist way of looking at I Dude, that's
not what it's
This girl knows nothing. Like this is weird. Whatever. >> I'm
not being like suffocated in this relationship. This What do
we do? Do we just sit here and like do our own things? Did he
feel like like
in unease cuz there was like silence and and time or like what
what did he specifically do that was like I feel like I'm
She says that like oh I'm not I'm not you know. Yeah. Clingy
is a good word for what she's describing. She's not. It's like
you literally irritated him so badly about the the cheating stuff
that he didn't want to talk to anymore.
Like you were the one on him about who he was talking to all
the time. And then you're like, "Well, he he loved me cuz I didn't
do these things."
A lot of people when they think there's millions of dollars at
play can hold that [__] back for a little bit. All
right. I don't know what the [__] he's >> I'm
being I'm being like tested one. I'm being like trained one.
Um, I feel like he I don't know. He just wasn't used to having
like a girl not be like up his ass and like worshiping him because
he's famous. And so I think it kind of had like an ego blow for
him and that's why he was so
like rough towards me.
>> Did you
I mean did you feel like he was like particularly aggressive
because he was upset or something?
>> Um, sometimes yes. And I can attest to this. Um, after
Kai went on a live stream with uh Liam, the guy that she cheated
on Tom with, Tom freaked the out and came to come see me and
was the most aggressive he had ever been towards me because of
that situation. And I think that is the same time that I told
my roommate about how aggressive he had
>> Okay. So, were you aware that this stream had happened?
That he was upset about it? >> Yes, because he told me
that uh that was the reason why he was upset.
>> How how long into the relationship was
>> Um that happened in October.
So, I guess Oh my gosh. When did we meet? I don't know. So, like
maybe like four or five months into it.
>> Okay. Um, but you said he started really
really early, right? Like like after a couple times you met him,
he would just start like hitting you like slapping you like in
the face. >> Yeah. Yeah. During Yeah. He wouldn't he never
discussed it with me that this was going to be a thing. He would
just start >> So just no warning. He just started slapping
you in the face. >> Oh, this gets brutal, man. >> Did
you like tell him? >> So we get both of them backing up
the same allegation, right? Same thing. Same
dude. It gets it gets brutal, though. >> I'm not okay with
this. >> I told him a couple times. I was like, "Why did
you slap me?" And he's like, "Oh, like I just I thought you like
that." And I was like, "I don't know. Like,
not really my thing." And then he
>> I don't know. I thought you like that. I don't know.
That's a bad answer. Okay. If you don't like getting slapped
in the face, that's a bad answer. >> He would continue
to do it to me after the fact.
Okay. Did you ever like explicitly say no in certain terms? Don't
do that. >> No, because usually it was in the middle of
and then he would be covering my mouth so I couldn't say no.
>> Okay. Oh, so he's like covering your mouth. Did you
ever like try to like break away from his grip?
>> Oh, this gets really brutal. Actually, this gets like
way way worse than this already.
I don't know. There's two I'm of two minds on this. You can absolutely
in the heat of the moment during
sneak some stuff in that the other person doesn't really like.
Okay, you can sneak you could do some that like they might not
want
and you know they don't want to kill the mood. They're going
to keep it going and then they'll
maybe they never get to discuss it after
you know like that is that is a thing that happens. the other
side of me and and maybe just never bring it up because it's
not that big a deal in the moment, right?
No, I'm not. Dude, I'm not saying they It's like they'll
you do something I don't even want to name anything. Okay.
But I don't know. They like you're like weirded out by foot fetishes
and they like lick your toe or something. Okay. This is not a
situation I've ever been in. It's literally I tried to come up
with something that's totally disjoint from my life. Okay. All
right. So, like something like that. And it's like, well, [__]
it. You know, this is really hot otherwise. I let that go cuz
that's like some weird [__] I don't really like that,
but hey,
I let it go. And then you just don't really bring it up until
later cuz it's like sort of aligned with some stuff you thought
was okay and you never really bring it up. But like if it's a
significant violation, I can't imagine not bringing up in a long-term
relationship. Yeah.
>> so you you can do stuff like that that probably you
know the other person doesn't really like that you shouldn't
be doing that you kind of have an idea they don't like but it's
like adjacent to some stuff that's okay and you like kind of
and it's a way of like violating a boundary or towing over towing
over the line on a boundary. Do you know what I mean?
You guys
you guys are focusing too much. It's like I can't I can't find
a way to use the language that you guys will not joke about and
can understand and take seriously,
but it's there's basically small violations you can do in the
moment. And this is I would say this is actually like an I this
is something that you could call abusive, right? That like somebody's
told you this is wrong to do,
you consistently backslide into doing it again.
This is something that's like actually getting towards being
abusive. And she's describing it in a way that I do think happens,
but a lot of people are like, "No, no, no. You have to advocate
for yourself in situations." It's like, "Oh, it's right on the
line for me. This is right on the line, dude."
>> Yeah. And he he would just like pull me
>> So, I couldn't >> You need that whole statement
as one
>> Okay. Oh, so he's like covering your >> Oh, hold
on. >> Okay. Did you ever like explicitly say no in certain
terms? Don't do that. >> No, because usually it was in
the middle of and then he would be covering my mouth so I couldn't
say no.
>> Okay. Oh, so he's like covering your mouth. Did you
ever like try to like break away from his grip?
>> Um, yeah. And he he would just like pull me harder.
>> Okay. Dude, I don't Man, it's hard for me to know if
I really believe all of it, but it is the thing is like sort
of it is funny. Okay, that she's like, "No, I couldn't say anything
cuz she he had my mouth covered." And he's like, "Did you try
to get away?" And she's like, "Yeah, but that only made him pull
me in harder." Like, dude, what? >> Yeah. But then after
that, you would like complain to to friends privately, but you
didn't like sit them down and say like, "I'm not okay with this."
I can explain this part. The one time >> so the time that
he was particularly rough after
um the Kai interview
>> uh did did like this so like anonymous like did it seem
like he was trying to like not look at you in the process? I
don't know if that makes sense or if what I'm getting at
>> Wait, did I miss that part already? I might have missed
that a little earlier. I was like sometimes not totally focused.
She did say that like the worst time that he was aggressive and
like abusive during
is after Kai did a stream with lyrics.
Like Kai did a stream with lyrics and he like lost his [__]
and came in and just like
brutally beat her ass while her. It's like dude are you
are you okay? Are you all right? Are you
lyrics just whack whack whack whack. [__] you, dude.
Null's trying to be like, yeah, he was obsessed with Kai, right?
And it's like, no, he's actually obsessed with lyrics, tell you
the >> Doesn't make sense. But >> yes, because this
is very, very graphic. and I'm sorry, but um he basically would
throw me onto the bed and shove my face down so I couldn't say
anything and and like just repeatedly like
have with me. And so I was basically just like laying there while
he did that to me and would hold my head down really
>> Okay. And would this also last for like an hour like
each time?
Yeah, it would last pretty long.
>> Okay. And it would bleed. Uh the same. >> This
is one of those moments from like, "Oh, Josh. Yeah, Josh, you
gripping it right now. Josh, you gripping it. You need to chill,
man. You need to chill."
>> Okay. And would this also last for like an hour like
each time?
>> Yeah, it would last pretty long.
>> Okay. And you would bleed uh the same. >> And
you didn't stop?
>> Yeah, I would bleed almost every time.
because it would last so long. >> See, that's pretty bad.
>> There's like no arousal after
>> How long? Okay, >> that might not be the thing.
People think there's like no arousal. No, it's like a it's like
a physical limitation.
Um often it's like an exhaustion, like a muscle fatigue kind
of thing, but it's like um it's not really necessarily that there's
no arousal there. It's just like a physical limitation. >> And
like with the lube, did you ever say like you have to use lube
cuz this is painful? He did get lube at one point, but he only
used it like once. And he said that he would just use it to draw
off usually. >> Dude, what the thing that could have saved
him so many times was right at his fingertips the whole the whole
time. And he's like, "No, that's my off loop.
Make you not bleed." You [__] Blood is lube. Okay.
This is for when I got to off. What? Am I supposed to cut my
hand or something? Am I supposed to cut my hand to drink off?
No, I use that lube, man. >> Wow. Okay, so he How early
into the relationship did you notice that he was
>> You need lube to off and something's gone wrong. I actually
disagree. Second
loop lube to drop off is not the worst thing in the world. I
don't It's not like an every time thing,
man. I should not I forgot. I don't like talking about this stuff
on stream, but it's not. You got You got that kicking around,
man. It's not the worst. Is that the worst
filming you um without without discussing it? >> Um this
had to be like over the summer. I'm not sure of an exact date,
but maybe like 2 or 3 months into our relationship, he would
like he never asked me. He would just pull out his phone and
record
and
I wouldn't notice until maybe 30 seconds and a minute or a minute
into it. And what really concerned me about this is that I was
like, "You know what? Okay. Like, he's just filming me drinks."
But I had asked him multiple times if he could please send me
the videos. So, like, he's not the only one who has videos of
me naked. And he either ignored the question or was just like,
"No."
So he's how many times did you ask? >> Hold on. That's
a big deal. What she should have done and I don't know. Maybe
she didn't do it. Dude, if there were DMs like this, it would
like actually this would be like over if she had DMs where she
was like, "Hey, you recorded us. Can I get that video?" And he
just said no or didn't answer. Those DMs would be like she'd
it'd be open to shut,
right?
If it's a consensually recorded video, of course you're going
to share it.
The only reason, so she could just be lying,
right?
But the only reason in my mind you'd record a video consensually
and they go, "No, I'm not sharing that with you." Is cuz you
know you did something weird. You know, it's evidence of wrongdoing,
right? Or maybe your face is in it. I guess maybe your face could
be in it and you're like, "Well, I'm the famous one." But again,
that's I feel
then it's more evidence that it's non-consentually recorded actually
because if the person said wanted the video, why wouldn't they
like actually negotiate that ahead of time? I don't
>> Maybe like three or four times.
>> And that was that was all after
um the the the four four month thing, right? Because I remember
that you mentioned that you were trying to get the videos because
you were starting to get like afraid of them and he just wouldn't
give it to you.
>> Did you ever feel afraid to leave him? >> I did.
I did. I was scared to leave him because of the videos and I
know that he has like a big platform and he could probably say
some about me or like I don't know. Like I it's the same thing
with Kai. Like I know he has some crazy [__] on her
and like God bless you Kai, but like
>> you guys are laughing.
Why are you laughing? Why are why why are people going, "Oh my
god, stop, you stupid bitch." Hold on.
Why are you guys saying this? We have multiple confirmations,
including Kai. Kai came out went, "Yeah, I know he's got a blackmail
folder on me." Why are you laughing? This is like a totally justifiable
Dude, Tom comes to you, says, "I have a blackmail folder on my
ex." His ex comes out and goes, "Yeah, he's definitely got a
black noer on me." They know what they signed up for. Oh, you
are totally
You are gone. Hero is overdosing. You're off this planet.
Please don't just listen.
You are an insult. Just please stay that way. All right. Nobody
deserves that. >> I know that he has some [__]
on you and I kind of felt the same way. >> Oh, Junarch.
You thought that was funny, eh? You're laughing. You're laughing
right now. Okay. At least you said says you cuz you're sitting
here saying the same thing he is. I just didn't single you out
first. Okay. >> You're referring to was the name of it.
It's they call it the blackmail folder but it had a name like
just in case. >> He called it the just in case folder.
>> Is that like literally the name of it on his desktop?
>> Okay. And you never saw inside of it. You have no idea
what's inside of it? >> No, I never looked. >> That's
okay. Okay. Okay. Are you worried that he's going to like
>> The thing that I think she doesn't want to say, she
comes close to saying it is that while this guy was non-conensually
recording and that would normally be a dealbreaker for her, he
was very rich. He was very rich. He looked like a good long-term
prospect. So maybe that's something. Listen, if we're going to
get married, maybe it's not that big a deal that he non-conensually
records me. I truly believe that's the most likely thing she
thought in her head was like, "Oh, this guy's rich. He's like
got it made. maybe I can deal with this. And I think she doesn't
want to say that. And most people would feel no sympathy for
that rationale, right? Oh, you got recorded because you didn't
want to say, but I get how
it doesn't make it right that he did that, right?
It doesn't make it right.
So, I get why people don't feel bad, but it would have happened
the first time without their consent. Hypothetically, if it did
happen, obviously might never have evidence of that. and it doesn't
make it right. Even if their even if their intentions were bad,
you don't get to bad people. You don't get to like violate the
consent of bad people. You get to violate the consent of bad
people. It's not how it works, man. Okay. That's just It's not
how it works.
>> Honestly, I don't know. I don't know what he's done
with the videos. I I don't have access. >> Oh, hold on.
I should pull it back. Null >> and he never saw inside
of it. >> No, I never looked. >> That's okay. Okay.
Okay. Are you worried that he's going to like revenge?
>> Honestly, I don't know. I don't know what he's done
with the videos. I I don't have access
to them, but
I don't know. I think that would be people's like main question
is like if you think that this guy is like violently aggressive
and has videos of you naked like why
I I figure I guess now would be the appropriate time a question
I like to ask people um who we talk to like this is in an ideal
situation
>> who we talk to you talking to a lot of victims bro
I is null talking to a lot of victims on his platform here I
actually don't know >> what is like the outcome of this
conversation like if you controlled like the threads of fate
what happens after this this uh discussion.
Um, I want to stop talking about it on social media and just
go actually
figure out a way to get those videos and
um maybe get the police involved because
>> uh I mean I think she did the worst play she could have.
If she suspects that those videos were recorded and saved,
she probably should have just gone to the cops first,
right? Or in tandem. It's bad to be here like days later and
you have not gone to the cops. It's not the worst, but like when
you find out about it, you should go to the cops in my opinion.
>> I don't I just honestly what makes me nervous is that
I am kind of I'm not an internet person. I'm >> I guess
sorry. If you want to go to the cops, if you want justice, some
people just want to get the story out and then disappear and
be like, "Ah, well, warning you, this guy's a weirdo."
Which is okay. But if you do want to go to the cops, if you want
to seek justice that way, you should do it. >> I'm not
trying to I wasn't ever in it for like, you know, I want to get
a bunch of clout like famous, but I'm just nervous that he's
going to do this to like so many other women. >> So, it's
like like one part like self-interested. I kind of want to like
force him to like delete my folder on his computer. And then
like >> again, uh land guy, I already explained this to
you. It doesn't mean you get to violate the person's consent.
Even if she just wanted it specifically because, sorry, even
if she just allowed it because he was rich. That doesn't mean
her consent gets to get violated. Doesn't make it not a crime.
It just it doesn't. And you have to think about the guy kind
of guy who's doing that repeatedly, who multiple women have accused
of doing that. He's a threat to other people, right? What is
the threat to the community if that guy just gets to keep doing
it? I'm sorry. I'm so sorry. Do you understand how consent works?
Yes.
Do you
I just said you don't get to record somebody just because they
might allow it and then later they're like, "Well, he's rich,
so maybe I should just let this happen." That's not consent.
>> Don't date this guy cuz he's like
>> Okay.
Katie, do you have a different interest? Do you like
What would you >> I just felt bad for her. Like I don't
know. I
like as an internet girl, I was like whatever these other
these like other girls will either come out about it or something
will happen like I I like didn't want and also like just being
a girl on the internet I did not want to deal with like dog piling
or anything so I just never said anything but then when
>> as a girl of the internet as a girl of the internet
>> sack came to me I felt bad because it was like okay
now he's targeting like normal Tinder women who like aren't like
internet girls who kind of know his
>> And so that was like the only reason I came forward
was to like help add like sentiment to what she's saying. And
like also yeah like
>> you guys met because you were mutuals through Tom like
you see >> she DM'd me. I don't am I okay with like explaining
this sack?
>> She DM'd me and was like I think we're talking to the
same guy.
This is the moment where I'm like, "Oh, this Sacramento [__]
This Sacramento [__] actually DM'd a bunch of women.
I'm sorry." She's like, "I'm the normal one. I'm the normal one."
And he was really annoyed that I kept bugging him about who he
was talking to over and over. And then I DM'd a bunch of these
people on on Instagram to see who he was talking to. And I I
called open with, "Hey, do you talk to Turkey?" I think we talked
to the same guy. You talked to Turkey Tom, right, bro? Yeah.
You're the normal one. You're the normal one. Get the out of
here. And I lit and I literally because she's so normal thought
she was a bot and was like what I was like I was like girl what
the hell are you I was like I'm not talking to anyone. What are
you talking about? And then after a little back and forth we
she was like we talked and it was like turkey Tom and I was like
girl I haven't talked to him in 3 years but like
how you know about this girl if you if Tom hadn't talked to her
in three years and you know about this girl. How'd you find out
about this girl? Be honest. Be honest.
How'd you find out about this girl? Did you just shock it out
DMs to a bunch of different women? That's wild to me that she's
Sorry, this is Katie talking now. Okay, Katie's the girl who
said, "I'm a girl of the internet or whatever." Yeah, Clorox
Katie, but but Sacramento is the one who DM'd her. So, Sacramento
DM'd this Clorox Katie girl and that's how they started talking
and eventually went to Kiwi Farms, I think, together after talking
for a bit, right? And in my opinion,
I think I think Sacramento was DMing a bunch of the EA girls
that Tom knew,
but we'll see. We'll see if that ever >> What's up? Like
why? Like why do you think that? Like what's happening? And then
she spilled the beans to me and I was like I was like you need
to say this somewhere. Like this is not like normal. The fact
that he like tried to hide everything from you and everything
is just like weird. And then and I didn't even know about this
whole Ellie later lady or anything until she told me about it.
And she I she didn't even tell me like the validity of it. I
learned all from like the thread.
>> Um how what like how do I word this? Is he like your
first boyfriend or second?
>> Yeah. Both of you.
>> Uh he's he was like my like third boyfriend probably
but but again it wasn't really like a boyfriend.
Um, he was my
I guess my second boyfriend
>> and you met him.
>> No, the normal one is not saying she got DM'd. That
was Clorox. Katie was saying she got DM'd by the Sacramento girl
>> when you were what ages.
>> I was like 20 21. >> I was 20.
>> And he was like 24, right?
>> Um, he was 22 turning 23.
Uh, okay. So, when
he had told Katie
>> Wait, that means Tom's still 23, right? >> She
was number three and number five. She had he had two and then
four like >> I was his I was his second body and then and
then he told me that he had four bodies the next time I saw him.
>> Okay. And null ask how long those two beings were apart.
Can anybody is there anybody who actually beyond what I tell
you? Is there anybody here who looks into this on their own?
Is there anybody here who knows that answer? What is the gap
between Clorox Katie's first visit and her second visit? Does
anybody know that or is it on me to know all of that
>> And he told you 15, right?
>> Um, yes. And to be specific, he told me
15, but I lost track.
So >> Oh, okay.
So between
>> No, it is my job. It is my job to know that that's my
bad. >> March 23
May 25,
he had sex with
>> 24. Okay. So in just over a year, >> he had at
least one encounter per month
>> Yes. Basically. Yeah. >> Okay. The Okay. I remember
one the number one thing that really stood out from all the messages
and this is just funny to me personally. Okay. Because of who
I am. Uh after you said that after 4 months in you found the
Kiwi Farms,
>> Uh yeah. >> And then after that he could not maintain
an >> I'm trying to think of exactly because I
>> dude
Josh
is very interested in this man's. Okay.
God damn. But this is a this is weird. This is a weird detail
that I don't know how causal I think this is.
>> I like some other theories here too. And then after
that he could not maintain an >> I'm trying to think of
exactly because I confronted him about all the girls and I started
really being on his ass in
and um then as soon as
um basically as soon as I told him about Kiwi Farms and like
the fact that I knew everything, we went to go meet his family
and during that whole trip he
it's possible that he was like emotionally compromised for some
reason and he couldn't get his dick hard.
But realistically,
if he's like one of these guys, if he's like watches a ton of
it all the time, can't maintain steady like ever,
I do wonder if he wouldn't have gotten like medication for that
and maybe going away he like didn't pack it or
Because if he's going from like, yeah, he couldn't come. He for
like hours. I I it I wonder if that doesn't solve this that it
wasn't like that he got told about Kiwi Farms. It's that he went
on a trip and didn't pack his like his
and then he had problems and then he didn't have problems any
other time.
Is that is that possible? >> Keep them if I can, but you
can have if you really want. >> So was how many months
was was it just
So you went on a family trip and it was during the trip where
he had problems and that was right after you had a confrontation
with him and that was around the fourmonth mark around the same
time. >> Wait a four I guess it was in December.
I don't know how long that is from when we first met. >> That's
near the end if if you guys met in May. >> Yeah, it was
near it was near the end.
>> Okay. So
way towards the end, you confronted him about all the Instagram
>> and all the e girls and you said that you knew. >> O,
yet another tremendous voice crack from Josh here. >> Dude,
am I the only person who's like undefeated on this?
Is there a single, By the way, my voice is consistently like
getting right on the edge as we are hitting winter and it's very
dry out,
but I have not I I don't think I've had a significant voice crack
on stream
and am I the only one at this point? Cuz I feel like everybody
else I listen to it's just consistent.
I feel like I'm rocking like an undefeated record right now >> about
his stuff on.
>> Okay. So,
way towards the end, you confronted him about all the Instagram
>> and all the e girls and you said that you knew about
his stuff on Kiwi Farms and then immediately after that you had
a trip together.
>> Okay. Uh you're just wrong, Stephen Jellian. You're
just wrong.
I mean, if nobody can post evidence,
if a tree voice cracks in the forest, did it really voice crack
at all? >> He just couldn't get it up at all. And >> then
the relationship ended after that.
>> Yes. Because he started being like really weird and
distant
>> and I was like getting kind of concerned and I was like,
"Okay, well, like
>> you don't yell as much as consistent crackers." What?
I yell way more than Queman does. I probably yell more than Stylo
does. Those are the two most consistent voice crackers I've seen
>> There's obviously something to what I told him because
he wouldn't have this reaction if this was like a nothing burger.
So I was like, "Huh, that's weird." And I kept being on his ass
about it and then we broke up and I was like, "Okay, well,
you're you're a freak." I don't know. >> Did was it like
did he break up with you or did you just say like, "I'm done.
You're like a freak. Goodbye."
I kept kind of like trying to get him to just leave me because
I would keep saying like like
>> I feel like I sense cope.
I feel like I sense cope.
Feel like I totally >> you've done all this like weird
>> Going back just a little bit more. I kept kind of like
trying to get him to just leave me because I would keep saying
like like you're you've done all this like weird [__]
like I don't like it like you're so weird you treat me badly
especially during and like over over the phone I just listed
everything that he had done wrong and he was like well you can
leave me if you want and I was like yeah I think I'm going to
leave
>> I'm not going to do a start a stream right now I'm not
going to let it interrupt my segment on Turkey Tom's X is opening
up his personal life for all to see all in sunundry. All right,
we got to finish this one up and then maybe we'll do some sardust
a little bit later. We'll see if we can street dust. That's not
that doesn't work. Are the women credible in this interview?
One of them seems fairly not credible. Um but it's hard to tell.
The other one seems like kind of credible, but they both have
flaws. Like major flaws.
There's there's problems here. I don't think Tom will ever get
anything criminal from >> Like it like you're so weird.
You treat me badly, especially during sex. >> Um, let's
uh let's back it up about 30 >> You're a freak. I don't
know. >> Did was it like did he break up with you or did
you just say like I'm done? You're like a freak. Goodbye.
>> I kept kind of like trying to get him to just leave
me because I would keep saying like like you're you've done all
this like weird [__] like I don't like it. Like you're
so weird. You treat me badly especially drinks. And like over
over the phone, I just listed everything that he had done wrong.
And he was like, "Well, you can leave me if you want." And I
was like, "Yeah, I think I'm going to leave you."
That's basically what
>> Um, did did he do the in front of the to the videos
thing, too?
>> Like how often,
>> you know, a one time thing?
I've seen him do it a couple times and it was usually to like
a video like he had just taken of me. >> Okay, that's so
bizarre.
>> This is like a really awkward question to ask, but I
have to know.
I'm pretty sure I heard null and unzip on this one. Whatever
this is, this is going to be a while. I'm pretty sure I heard
it.
I don't know how to ask this, but you know,
I have to know, dude. The whole interview, man. He's He's just
gripping it hard. Hold on. I'm backing it up. I'm just getting
some water and I'm going to mix some caffeine up cuz I have been
up since like [__] 8 a.m. today. I'll be right back.
Okay, that's so bizarre.
>> This is like a really awkward question to ask, but I
have to know cuz it is a chicken and egg problem. Did he ever
finish like from having >> He did a couple of times
>> this guy. This guy ever come. This guy This guy ever
come.
>> This sounds really terrible, but
>> what was the color inconsistency? >> He uh he
could only finish from if I was screaming and crying in pain.
>> Okay. How often was was it like I guess he didn't ask
>> what? What?
What? I need the Jontron.
Oh my goodness. That's uh that's tough
>> From if I was screaming and crying in
>> Okay. How often was was it like I guess he didn't ask
for that, right? He would just like like hit you until that
He would be hitting me and like choking me and slamming me down
until I was like screaming in pain because he wouldn't stop having
with me either. And only
>> Okay, this starts to sound way worse. This is like not
at all. Did she think about maybe delivering, you know, part
of this in the
Kiwi Farms post? Jesus Christ. THIS IS LIKE SO MUCH WORSE.
This is so much
I will say it does sound like pretty
Ah, like maybe it's true,
but screaming and crying in pain, I don't I don't know. I'm trying
to think of like what under what circumstances could feel like
it's true. >> I guess he didn't ask for that, right? He
would just like like hit you until that happened.
>> He would be hitting me and like choking me and slamming
me down until I was like screaming in pain because he wouldn't
stop having sex with me either. and >> like tossing her
around a ring like wrestling like he's Andre the Giant that's
how he gets off >> when I was like ah my god like stop
then he could come
>> okay so it's literally the words like stop stop is like
>> like eight every time
>> um he only was able to
ejaculate
um maybe three times
throughout our whole
that's like at that point
at that point that's um that's bad, man. That's too much.
That's too that's too much, man.
Like you you got something you got something going on. If that's
true, by the way, like literally a lot of this could be false
if we don't have actual proof for it, right? But it doesn't feel
like it's all made up. If that's true, you're Dude, just stop
jerking off. You're that's that's a problem. That's got to be
a problem when you're that age, right? That you just can't come
or or a cope problem, but >> Okay, Katie, is this like
consistent with your experience or is this like >> Yeah,
the first time I met him, he didn't come a single time and he
just told me it was like cuz he was nervous and I was like, I
mean, makes sense, whatever. And then the second time, he only
came the one time that he watched the video. But,
>> okay, I just want to make it clear to the the younger
audience here, this is not normal. And if this is what is required
for you to finish during
um you have issues.
I just want to make I don't I don't
I mean this is true
but I don't think I don't think null has a great idea of what's
normal either. I
it's not quite pot calling kettle black because obviously the
Tom stuff's way outside the norm in like a super negative way.
But
>> I don't know how many people need to hear that. That's
really messed up and um implies that there has to be like some
level of like non-consent in your encounters. That's probably
like I'm just thinking cuz all the serial killers said that they
were really addicted to it's like that sounds like a stepping
stone to like becoming a serial killer is when you have to have
like blood and screaming and to ejaculate.
>> That's kind of how I felt.
>> Yeah. Tom is a serial killer. Yeah. So, Sacramento,
you were talking to like your friends throughout this relationship,
right? Did any of them >> like you I I saw some texts where
you were telling them and they were concerned or maybe that was
just Katie. Did anybody like warn you? Like this is messed up.
You should probably leave. >> Yeah. My friends told me,
you know, this is never ever okay. Like >> I know that
he has money and all of that, but you shouldn't just stay with
him. Like you're you're worth so much more than that. and just
trying to be like supportive. But unfortunately, I did still
stay with him. And I know a lot of people seem to have a lot
of questions about that. And
honestly, you were completely correct to question my judgment
as to why I stayed with him even though he was, you know, hitting
and choking and beating me. >> I mean, what could is there
any thought process behind
>> like not leaving? I guess it's easier to stay in a relationship
in general than to leave. It's like a hard decision to do that.
>> So, is it just like, you know, I'm I'm in school and
I don't want to like change up my life. >> There's like
a lot of things that could be going on here, but
donated $3.
>> Another serial killer with an animal name. First Buffalo
Bill, now this guy.
>> True. Could buy
horses.
Wow. Um, what was I about to say? I lost it. Thank you for the
donation though. It was worth it. Is >> there any thought
process behind
is there any thought process behind you staying in this like
abusive
I I would say probably most people who stay in abusive relationships
pro probably aren't acting rationally. There's not really a a
thought process. It's like, I think this person cares about me
and they're going to get better. They wouldn't treat me like
this, right? I think that's usually what >> Like not leaving.
I guess it's easier to stay in a relationship in general than
to leave. It's like a hard decision to do that.
So, was it just like, you know, I'm I'm in school and I don't
want to like change up my life too much by like breaking this
off early or
>> I I genuinely did think that he would maybe change and
stop being so aggressive
because he told me before that he would like kind of chill out,
but he never did chill out and it kept being the same very
intense violent aggression every single time. >> Yeah.
It it wasn't like tied to anything, right? It was never like
a bad day. And just so you know, even in like BDSM stuff, you're
never supposed to like take real life anger and turn that into
like that's also like a red flag in general for anyone who needs
to hear that. So yeah, my my question is he was just always like
this. There was never a time where it's like, you know, today
today, you know, let's just have it. It's like always every time.
Um, yeah, it was always aggressive, but like I said before, during
the times when Tai started coming out with like that guy that
she's with, Liam, he would be so angry and take his aggression
out on me, especially hard dur encounters.
>> And there was no for either of you, there was no point
at all where he was >> Dude, that's so rough, man. That's
so rough that she's just sitting here like she like has she has
lyrics. She has the Liam Donovan stream favorite on every platform
so she can get notifications. If it says Kai in the title, she
like gets she goes to Amazon and like buys her cover up makeup,
like her concealer for all the bruises. She's like, "Well, I'm
going to have to explain this to people." Well, I guess I GUESS
I'M IN for it tonight. Oh boy.
>> Like interested in like, "Oh, was it good for you?"
Like, >> no. Oh, no. He never asked.
>> Cool. Um, did A big question a lot of people had. There's
been speculation that he's because he's made weird comments about
finding men attractive on his streams. Did he ever come across
as like heteroplexible
or anything like
>> Another voice. >> Um I say
>> ever talk about sucking dick. Oh, this is a good part
though. Hold on. This is a great part. Just wait. in the sense
that like for one he said that weird thing about Destiny and
he was like hella obsessed with Destiny at that time and was
like talking about him and hanging out with him a lot >> and
then and like going to Miami to see him and then also he would
like because he like lifts weights and stuff, he would like watch
videos of other guys like lifting and like flexing and stuff
and literally be like
like oh my god. And I and like to me like he would sit there
and like act like it's cuz like oh they're so strong. But to
me I was just like I don't care how strong they are. That that
sounds gay.
>> Sit there and like moan for a strong >> Yeah.
To expand on that he told >> Hold on. Hold on.
>> Yeah. To expand on that. He told me a little bit about
the Destiny guy. Um that he had went to go visit him. Um he told
Katie that he went to go visit him four times total. Um but yeah,
the Destiny guy from what he told me was gay and wore a butt
plug during their
So Destiny was wearing a butt plug in front of
>> dude. Dude,
wait. How did Tom know? How did Tom
That's a That's the question I want the answer to. Is Destiny
the kind of guy who just rolls up to hang out and he's like,
"Hey, I got a I got a plug in. You good with that? Is that Is
that the RGR thing that you shouldn't be able to get off on some
fetish with the other person knowing? Hey, I'm I'm being gratified
currently. You need to know that to consent to us hanging out.
I just like did he let him know or did Tom find out somehow on
his own? What the [__] happened here?
I all I can say for sure is
yuck.
>> Gay and wore a butt plug during their
So Destiny was wearing a butt plug in front of Tom.
>> What?
What?
>> Yes. during so during like during his regular social
interactions with with Tom, he was just plugged up and told Tom
this and he was just okay with >> how how is this a two-hour
interview just trying to like Tom's career and Destiny gets like
the worst shot in it. Somehow somehow Destiny gets hit the hardest
in like a two-hour interview from Tom's long-term exes from one
of his long-term exes and there's just like a it's like a throwaway
line about Destiny and he's the most person in this interview.
That's That's crazy with
>> Uh, yes.
Why did this come out in conversation? Were you just asking him
about Destiny?
>> Um, yeah. I was He He would like bring up these internet
people and honestly, I'm so like normal like like Normie Pilled.
Like I I've not been super into the internet for the past few
years. And so I would have no idea what the hell he was talking
about. So I would ask him like, "Who is that?" And so he would
be like, "Oh, like this guy Destiny. He was a streamer I was
friends with and I found out he was wearing a butt plug when
I went to go visit him one time.
>> dude.
Dude,
wait. Hold on. Wait. Is that just Wait, wait, wait. Did we know
that? Did we know that already that like Tom that Destiny had
logs about being plugged up like on one of the days when Tom
went? When was Tom there for like bridges and was it one of those
days that he was there and then the Destiny logs come out and
he's like plugged up or something? Is that is that the case?
I don't think so cuz I think that's way before
I think those logs are like way before bridges started. Anyway,
I I think so. >> That's very funny. Many people will appreciate
that. He's very famous.
>> I mean, I guess on that note, did he tell you any other
weird stories about random people? >> Oh, I remember this
because his name I thought was funny. He told me he was
with this guy named Dick Masters.
>> Oh, no.
Okay, if Veto joins, I can ask about this. Veto, do you know
about Tom and you doing
you do you know about Tom and you doing like uh
together? Were you there for that? Veto. Veto was there there
for that. By the way, I know Dick and Veto have talked about
this on the show. How Bo Black totally blew up their spot that
Boax like got
Boax did coke with them and then just told everybody. He's like
so happy he got to hang out with the cool kids and do coke. They
just told everybody. I did I did coke with Dick Masterson in
a veto. I did coke with these guys. I did coke with these guys.
>> That's crazy. That's crazy.
>> He told me that was a couple years ago. But yeah,
>> I feel like I'm being trolled. That's such a specific
person. Okay, so he just went over Yeah, he was he's in LA with
Dick and uh he just said, "Yeah, we met up and we did a podcast
together and we did we had fun."
>> Yeah. Apparently, this guy lives in like a mountain
house, like a mountain compound that >> he's up in the
Hollywood Hills Barbie Dream Doll mansion. That's what he tells
>> And yeah, Tom was doing various drugs with this guy.
>> Okay. You both said that he talked about Kai or Kay
incessantly, right?
>> He talked about Kai a lot. I >> mean, how did
that make you feel, Zack? cuz you were like, "I don't want to
hear about this." >> Oh my god. Yes. And it made me feel
so weird. And I would I would bring this up to him and he was
like, "Well, she was like an insane like don't worry about it."
But I was like, "This woman clearly had some mental effect on
you if you're constantly talking about her and keeping up with
her new man. I mean, he showed me a picture of that guy Liam
wearing makeup and he was like, "Oh, this guy took my like just
like >> dude,
Tom comes off as like the most mentally individual in this."
Like he actually and I totally believe it unfortunately because
there's no like there's no legal connotation to this. there's
no like long-term consequence to this because of like because
of that in my opinion like this feels kind of credible that
there's also a chance that Tom was just making fun of him to
this girl,
right? There's a chance that Tom was just being
Look at this. This took my Look at this cute This cute took my
some like that, right? This this fanboy stole my [__]
I I don't know. It maybe it wasn't just seething. Probably was
seething though.
You believe these girls for real? Not on everything. I just I
literally just gave you an outline for why I might believe this
whereas opposed to some other things I don't necessarily believe.
Right. Right. >> Like raging and I was like, "Okay, he
clearly not over this girl." >> I think I have a picture
of him. He He just looks like an affeminite boy like in the pastel
colored clothes. Right.
Um, yeah. Oh, I think I have a picture of him. He's like the
fanboy, right? Right.
Is it Liam wearing makeup fairly recent? Yes. The girl that's
talking, the the Sacramento girl only broke up with Tom earlier
this month. >> Yeah, he's like a fem boy. >> I found
Tom implying Destiny wore the plug during their Bridges podcast.
It was ironic as though. Wait, what? Wait, what? Wait, what?
Wait, what? What?
Hold on. Let me click on this. What is this? What is this? >> Okay,
just, you know, let's let's get really hypothetical about this
right now. All right, look at this video. Okay, is he wearing
it? Is it in?
Is it in J? Oh, that dude. Goatees are never the answer. Goatees
are never the answer. Goatees are horrifying. You literally you
never look more like a than having a goatee.
It's like terrible. Genuinely, is it in?
Like I'm not even I'm not even like around here. Just out of
genuine cur like is it in? There's a nonzero chance. Look, he's
he looks a little distressed. I feel like dude, it's very possible.
Like we have to assume. I mean, look, we don't have Oh, this
is why this is why Desu is so ped to Tom, isn't it? Cuz this
is after the November leaks. This is after the butt plug logs,
but before the lawsuit. This is after everything's leaked but
before the law
>> rean Ruben donated $3. Tom is ruining the vibes for
real. >> Direct evidence but there certainly is a possibility.
There's also a large possibility that this stream is brought
to you by today's sponsor gamers.g.
>> Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow.
And yeah, so when Kai I I think when she left him or they broke
up or whatever,
um she hooked up with this guy
and now he is the one doing the age play. Like he
>> dude,
Null is like so far behind on Null is like not committed to this
stuff. You know what I'm saying? Null could have been committed
to this stuff. Null is just like, "Yeah, I've heard of this guy."
Like, he's the one doing age, but he doesn't he's not really
looked into it that much, you know? >> You know, he's just
not that he literally looks like a little boy. Um, it's really
bizarre. I don't know if I have a picture of it or show people,
but yeah, it was it was very strange. Did he ever bring up age
play like explicitly with either of you? >> Not really.
No. Like cuz again like he we never like talked about like anything
we were into like Exactly. He just like would say things that
it was like, "Oh, well, it's implied obviously that you're into
this."
No. No. Weird like, "Can you dress up like this?" Besides just
gifting you like Hello Kitty stuff. >> No. I mean, he would
tell me drinks like, "Oh, like you're like a little girl. You're
so skinny. Like, you're so small." It was It was like really
weird, but I was just like, "Oh, well,
>> I'm here.
into about it now.
>> What else am I going to do? >> I'm not a I'm not
a
>> I mean, I hate to ask this. Did he ever ask for like
[__] or was it just like brutal like every time?
>> Oh my god. Sorry. This is like so personal. But yeah,
he would he would make sure that you did that. But he never did
anything back to me. Like he never once ate me out, but he would.
Tom knows that eating box is gay. >> Demand that I would
constantly suck his dick and like Yeah.
>> Was he able to finish from that or was it just like
a for show thing?
>> Oh, this is where this is where Tom
Tom's [__] up here. Okay. Tom is very [__]
up here.
Or sorry, Tom. No, null. Null is up. Null is up for this. Okay.
>> He wasn't able to finish from that
So you would just have to be like
>> null doesn't understand why you'd want a [__]
if you're not going to finish from the [__]
There's like so many other like it's obviously like purely downstream
of everything else Tom says he likes about like dominating and
all this. It it's so it's like this is like a purely
person null. It's like he doesn't get it. It's so weird. >> Down
in the in the mines for like an hour at a time until he was bored.
>> Yeah.
Okay. Wow, that sounds like a lot of fun.
>> Yeah. I don't Katie, can you kind of >> Yeah,
I'm Same thing. Just like Yeah, he would always want a head,
but then he is never like giving head and also same of like never
came and it Yeah, it was just like for
>> uh Hold on. Yeah, if these genders were reversed, these
questions would be considered like evil. Wait, no, they're evil
either way. Like the the questions are totally inappropriate.
I would say the only reason we wouldn't cover this if it was
like some random private citizen. It just it's because it happens
to be Turkey Tom, right? A guy who is quite literally
done this like a bar a pretty much equivalent level of mining.
You just saw Destiny was like his buddy and he's like mocking
Destiny for having a plugin pulling up his podcast when Destiny's
like
literally getting cancelled like when it's over for Destiny.
You know what I'm saying?
like, well, sorry, it's actually a little bit before the lawsuit
when things really popped off. So, there's we're kind of in that
weird like
we're in that radiation sickness phase where Destiny was a dead
man walking, you know.
So, maybe it's, but it was still pretty rough that he was doing
that to his body >> almost. It was very odd. >> Former
buddy
that is that is really bizarre cuz it's like if you're not what's
the point then besides like I guess like the power play and I
guess recording it for him cuz he would record this too, right?
Yeah, you recorded everything.
>> Wow. Okay. So,
he didn't try to do any of the weird age play stuff, but he did
talk about her a lot. He said that you were very petite, very
small, I guess. Did he literally say you look like a little girl?
>> To both of you.
>> The first time I got naked in front of him, he literally
was like, "This is awesome. You look like a little girl."
>> Wow, dude.
Dude, there's no way, right? Like I I feel like we're getting
quite a bit of validation on the age play thing, but there's
just no way. There's no way that a girl takes her clothes off
and you're like, "Oh, awesome. You look like a toddler. You look
like a little girl." Okay, I said toddler, but that's not really
it. You look like a little girl. That's so cool. You look like
a Dude, there's no way. There's no way. >> And I was like,
"Oh,
>> I got to back it up again." >> The weird age place
stuff. But he did talk about her a lot. He said that you were
very petite, very small, I guess. Did he literally say you look
like a little girl?
>> To both of you.
>> The first time I got naked in front of him, he literally
was like, "This is awesome. You look like a little girl."
>> And I was like, "Oh, that's not normal." >> So
anyway,
you just I'll only you tops 10 times. Okay. Tops 10 times. I'll
only you 10
You just said something weird. I'm only you 15 times max. Okay.
>> Okay. I'm trying to think cuz Oh, the Kai thing I was
going to ask. You both read her her statement, right? Um just
in brief. Tell correct me if you think I'm summarizing this unfairly.
>> Oh, he is. I think he he doesn't get the Kai statement
in my opinion. Um, he he actually just straight up does not understand
the Kai statement at all, which is weird because he asked somebody
to DM him like the Aiden statement about Kai. He asked for it.
So, I'm I'm curious like did nobody me did nobody message him
the information cuz he gets this so wrong. Just so bafflingly
wrong. I'm I'm just confused hearing him speak on it. Like, it's
just weird that he got it so wrong when he lands his interview
and he gets this element like completely
But she put out this uh PDF and in it she effectively says
uh I dated Turkey Tom for a very long time when we started when
we were like high school age and then up until early 20s and
uh it was a very terrible relationship. We were both equally
awful to each other. Um, and
nothing that they said
about you brutal like dehumanizing is applicable to my experience
with him. But they might be right. I don't know. Like that's
basically what she said. It felt very strange. She did confirm
explicitly the blackmail folder though. She said that's completely
real. Which makes it sound like everything that she's saying
to downplay it is blackmailed cuz why would you why would you
bring that up? I mean, does that sound like a fair assessment
of the document that she just says, "We have a bad relationship."
>> Um, there's serious allegations being made. She believes
that your driving motivation is to humiliate him, and she says
that this is abhorentt is her exact word. She says she's not
addressing
any specific thing, but says that
uh he did record stuff,
but there was not like any violent degrading.
Um,
I mean,
Well, she says they mutually agreed to record stuff. Not quite.
Do you have any or do you >> like the reason, by the way,
the reason Kai put the document out is literally Aiden. Okay.
Aiden is the reason that Kai put the document out. Aiden came
out and said Kai's current boyfriend who streams who she lives
with told me that she did age play with Turkey Tom. She acted
like a 5-year-old for Turkey Tom or whatever the [__]
Okay. All right. That's not a direct quote. That's that's why
she put the document out. She says very specifically, right?
>> here, hold on. Um there has been a message circulating
claiming that Tom and I participated in age play. She put it
out for this reason. Everything else in this document basically
circles around this one accusation that was going to cook Tom
publicly, right? this confirmation from a third party from like
somebody who actually had a reason to like want to tell the truth
that hey this age play thing is very weird. She wanted to come
out and say that's wrong. People are lying about me. That's wrong.
So that is the that is the primary reason she made this. It it
is a a bit of a sweepy document and I do think she's probably
lying to be honest with you. When you look at the incentives
for who might be lying here, who could be lying, like all the
incentives are for her to lie. Even if it's if the age play thing
were true, she's still incentivized to lie, right? So, I I lean
towards she's probably lying here anyway. So, I think that's
But I don't even think the whole touches of that or knows the
context, which is weird. >> I mean, do do you have any
opinions >> first or do you want to go first, Zach? >> Uh,
you can go first. >> Oh, god. Okay. Um,
I I I agree with her like with Kai that they probably didn't
have like a fully like like he wasn't doing the same thing to
her as he's doing to other girls. And she even says in it that
like who knows what he's like after her. And I think that like
and he told me and Sack that uh Kai didn't like having sex with
him and didn't like giving head and that like they barely had
and I can imagine that it's probably because he is aggressive
and she probably didn't like doing it. So at one point she just
like stopped
>> Oh,
sorry. Sorry. Soapbox, quick update. Sobox. Sobox went on. He
got Quimma got on kick and Soapbox had to go to his chat and
throw this in here in his chat. Hey, you hypocritical piece of
[__] You have mocked and dunked on women so many
times with your boy also and now want to act like you're better.
Go [__] yourself, little [__]
Bro, why you crashing out, dog? It's not that serious, bro. Just
not that serious,
>> All right, we we keep going.
So I think like and I think that she like mentally him or something
to where Yeah. Because that's why he like
>> So true. She did mentally him. Okay. That's just >> after
her. And I think that like and he told me and Sack that uh Kai
didn't like having with him and didn't like giving head and that
like they barely had
and I can imagine that it's probably because he is aggressive
and she probably didn't like doing it. So I want
>> Nah. No, that's not what happened.
I think
I think Turkey Tom started going to the gym. He started watching
some Red Pill and he was like, "This is what like didn't like
me because I was a sensitive [__] This is what like
they want to be thrown around. They want to be told what to do.
They want to be mushed into the pillow." I That's 100%. It's
just an overreaction and overcorrection.
I think he didn't I think he didn't [__] high. I
don't think he ever got I don't I don't know. She said we did
do sub stuff. I don't know that Tom would have even gotten that
crazy with her to be honest with you.
I'm sorry. It's like it seems way more like just
thing >> and
so I think like and I >> she does say they did heavy subdom
dynamics. Did she say which partner was which? Hold on. Wait
wait wait. Turkey Tom Kai
uh doc
what? Doc Google turkey. What the is Kai's stupid doc called?
God damn it. Hold on. Let me go to my my own docket and grab
it from yesterday.
What's she turkey Tom allegations? That's what my called.
Okay. Where's the Dom sub dynamics message circulating?
Tom definitely romanticizes power dynamics and heavy dom sub
stuff, but this that was never expressed through age related.
Well, she says he did it. Uh, maybe it was after he got cheated
on. Maybe it was after he got maybe then.
Maybe. Maybe.
But I think that she like mentally him or something to where
that's why he like con like compares everyone to her still has
all her stuff.
>> Dude, we will have to do the Kaija review once the lyrics
arc has ended. Once Larry is fully transed out, once Lar gets
the surgery. Once Lar gets his dick shut snipped off. But I was
not sure what I was going to say there. Once Lar gets the surgery.
Okay. Okay, Kai's going to move on and we'll have to have the
the duo review for Turkey Tom's brain and Larry's ball sack.
Okay. >> And is like really weird about her and like stalks
her and her new boyfriend >> that I like I think that yeah,
it could have went like toxic but like mutually fine whatever.
But I think that's like why that's the reason he's like this
now is like something obviously was like in that relationship.
>> Yeah. Um,
I agree with I have specific things I want to bring up, but do
you have any Okay. >> any thoughts?
>> Yeah, I agree. I think that he definitely has some like
weird like limrance issue with her where he just couldn't let
her go. >> Li Oh, now we're using $5 words out here. She's
some He has some weird lirance with her really. And I also don't
think that she realized how badly whatever she did to him completely
him up. I mean, she did cheat on Tom with Liam, who was one of
his friends at the time, which I think is a pretty terrible thing
to do to someone, but >> um yeah, I agree. I don't think
that their relationship,
>> dude. the once once this dam does break, okay, there
will be a moment the dam breaks and one of these two starts firing
off leaks or something and the way you'll be able to go back
through time and see all of the awkward moments. I'm sure somebody's
got it archived. Probably his KF thread has got it archived,
okay, of just like Lex leaking his DMs with her and the moment
where Chud brings it up on the stream. Does anybody have that
clip? I would love to find that clip. Hold on, let me see if
I can find it. There's a moment where Chud Logic brings it up
on his stream. Chud Logic.
Chud Logic. Turkey Tom.
Cheating. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Not recent. Not
recent. Old >> the question you have to off.
Hold on. This is when Ah, yeah.
Okay. Tom joins here. Is it Is it here? Hold on.
Can we Does he ask about lyrics or something? No. Okay. Hold
on. What is he It's not going to be cheating. I think it's this
interview in this video, but I don't remember if it's is it right
at the end.
>> The same token, they would defend the women who cheat
a lot more and probably try to write it off as like they had
an abusive partner or something like that's my that's how I would
probably read it. Brute thing. >> So, thank you for doing
that. I appreciate it. >> Yeah, no worries. Right.
>> I don't like I don't feel the need. >> There is
some moment where Chud like straight up asked him about the cheating
stuff with with lyrics. It was during the NN stuff if I recall
correctly. If anybody could find that, I would really want to
watch that clip, but I'm I'm not going to be able to find it
right now.
it's going to take me too long. Some Chud logic lore master knows
>> might not have been abused or whatever. But I do think
that, you know, she confirmed a lot of the things that we said.
And I think that
uh he was kind of going after girls that look like her so he
could take his anger out on girls.
>> That's exactly what I was going to say. I was like it
really feels like just based off like the nature of it, like
the positions and stuff, it really feels like he's trying to
surrogate her so he can like punish her and that's why it has
to be like so >> Okay. Yeah, that's pretty dark. >> And
I agree that I feel like she's a little hush- hush and like uh
like vague on stuff because of the whole just in case file. Like
I I think it would just become like an evil war if they both
came out with act like if she came out with any actual damning
evidence, he probably would try to like destroy her
>> Yeah. I mean, the what the letter reads very weird to
me because number one, there's not like a thesis. It's not like
she's out there saying, "I want to make this clear."
>> Again, I think it's that I think it's that Tom was getting
blown the up and people were using her name to go after him a
lot and she wanted it to be very clear. Hey, hey, Psycho with
all this information on me. I didn't do this. I'm not supporting
this. I'm not going after you. Also, that Aiden guy is a lying
Jew. That was the core thesis. Okay. I'm not going after Tom.
Aiden is a lying Jew. core thesis right there. >> It's
like what are you even trying to say in the document? I don't
What's the >> It's very weird. She like go she says that
like she doesn't think that Tom's that evil, but she's also like
I can't attest, but also >> Yeah. Well, that's the other
thing is that she then goes on to say like I want to have my
I've been private about this. I want to remain private, but I'm
publishing this thing that has no purpose anyways. And then she
goes on to say like, "I didn't have these bad experiences, but
you can trust victims." And then she like
goes on to say like, "Yes, he has a blackmail folder on me."
And it just feels like it really sounds like you have a gun to
your head and you're trying to say something without saying anything
so that Tom's appeased, but you're not actually saying, "Yeah,
don't worry about it. He's fine." You know what I mean? >> Yeah.
That's kind of what I thought,
>> That's what we both thought.
Yeah. Yeah. That's that's bizarre. I don't know if they use this
word anymore, but it's called wanitis when I was a teenager.
>> Yeah, I know about wanitis. That's what I thought, too.
I literally my friends were saying that cuz I would tell them
about like the whole >> No, [__] Unking out
right now. >> Weird stuff.
>> when I when I browsed r/ the red pill, they called this
what it >> and they were like, he's got oneitis.
>> And in 2016, when I browsed r/ the red pill, they called
this oneitis, man. >> Thank god. Let me see if uh
I received any questions.
Um someone asked if he tried to get either of you to look like
her, but he did so passively through like gifts and stuffs.
Uh I asked if you Oh,
uh with Meowin the the puppy player.
Was there any
uh one itis is just obsession? You just like can't get over a
girl. Like basically you chase a girl, she you you either get
her for a little bit or you don't get her at all and then you
can't move on and go for like the next girl. It's like you're
obsessed with this girl who got away. >> The thing like
that you saw in regards to that cuz there are pictures of them
together and I I I feel it's pretty obvious that they had was
that during the time that you guys were together or was that
like before? Um, that was before, but I did end up asking him
about her during like my sussy kind of phase. And he said that
um they had met up before.
Um, they had never done anything. But keep in mind that he also
lied to me that he had never done anything with Ellie. Um but
um he also said that apparently she had been married before and
she is a devout Christian who only has one body and wants to
wait until marriage which kind of made me
have a weird feeling because how would you know that about someone
if you weren't trying to
>> you know that's that that's kind of not just someone
something you tell a business associate. It sounds like he tried
to then she was like, "I'm waiting till marriage. You got to
put a you got to put a collar on it." You know, he was like,
"I'm not doing that.
Bye."
Um, who which one of you I think it was Sacramento, but which
one of you was the one that had the eating disorder that he like?
>> Um, it was me >> and he like encouraged you to
to continue having an eating disorder or he was like complimenting
you or something,
>> Sorry, I'm backing up. I was Listen, I'm trying to do
multiple things. I'm trying to see that Stardust Crash Out might
be content. We'll see if it's going to be content. I'm not totally
sure. I'm I'm checking on a couple things. I missed the last
thing we said here.
>> Something you tell a business associate. >> It
sounds like he tried to. Then she was like, I'm waiting until
marriage. You got to put a you got to put a collar on it. You
know, like I'm not doing that. >> Oh, Meowin, right? Meowin.
Um yeah, sorry. This whole thing because I did listen to this
before. At least this section for sure.
This to me is another indication that Sacramento was like obsessing
over the other girls that she was he could have been with was
with,
Um that's the Sacramento girl from the thread. Canadian caller,
the one with the ED that that's the Sacramento girl from the
thread where she's like, "I'm not crazy like these other people.
I'm not crazy like these other people." And then she's like,
"Yeah, also I was institutionalized for an eating disorder and
I DM'd a bunch of his exes or people I thought he might have
[__] because I thought he was cheating on me." It's
like, dude, you are.
It's like, yeah, you went through his follows. You started messaging
people. I don't know what we're doing here, dog.
>> Bye.
Um, who which one of you I think it was Sacramento, but which
one of you was the one that had the eating disorder that he like?
>> Um, it was me. >> And he like encouraged you to
to continue having an eating disorder or he was like complimenting
you or something, right? Can you >> Oh, wait. Okay. Canadian
call. I don't know why you said that then. My bad. Um, yeah,
he would. I told him very early on like, "Hey, like I've struggled
with eating issues in the past and I'm kind of still trying to
gain some weight,
make sure everything's okay." And he would tell me, "Oh, I love
how skinny you are. I like how small you are, you know, like
I love how your body is like skinny." And like just say all this
stuff that was incredibly
hard to hear.
>> Yeah, that's really mean.
>> Like I don't know. I guess he wants
women that are as skinny as possible. I don't know. Did Did he
ever This would also be very >> I was institutionalized
because of my eating disorder. Oh, wow.
Yeah. Uh well, you do look great that skinny. What? You're overeating?
Yeah. Hey, listen. You're overeating. I get it. You are putting
on a couple pounds, but it's okay.
>> Could you imagine? >> Did he ever say like your
body looks like Kai's? No.
>> This guy's trying to drive a narrative so hard it's
very funny. >> Did you ever contact me? >> No. I
feel like she definitely knows some though. So Meowin, if you're
hearing this, please like,
it's okay. I know you're a puppy, but we don't care. Like
>> did he
did he ever talk in
Dude, we're um I'm getting I'm in a
I I got to see the picture that you know when we discussed the
Stardust stuff. I hate to the segment like this. You know when
we discuss the Stardust stuff, I'm getting to see what what Substance
actually put in the DMs
or sorry what he actually put in the replies. Bro, it is not
that bad in terms of like gore and stuff. It's not that bad.
Is really not that bad.
>> Like a baby voice or asked that you do >> He's
do the like weird baby voice. I know what you're talking about.
And he would do the weird baby voice sometimes. It's like a joke,
but it was like really scary. He sounded like a baby and he would
even do the thing where he like puts his legs up and like sucks
on his thumb like a baby.
Oh my god. >> That is so
>> Yeah, I agree. >> Wait, wait, that's not in a
context though, right? That's not that's not in a context. >> He
would he sounded like a baby and he would even do the thing where
he like >> talk in like a baby voice or ask that you do
it. >> Would he want you to talk in a baby >> Um,
he would do the like weird baby voice. I know what you're talking
about. And he would do the weird baby voice sometimes as like
a joke, but it was like really scary. It was really scary when
he did the baby voice as a joke.
>> Mommy, change my diaper. When he did that voice, that
was really terrifying for you. I would have thought I would have
thought it was when he was like beating you until you screamed.
But apparently it's mommy, please change my diaper. Change my
diaper now. Apparently that is the terrifying moment
>> cuz he would he sounded like a baby. And he would even
do the thing where he like puts his legs up and like sucks on
his thumb like a baby.
Oh my god.
>> Are you good at this? Cuz I'm good at impressions and
I've watched him do it now covering this content because everybody
wanted to do like the diaper thing like laughing about the diaper
thing and when he ever he does the diaper stuff he does the baby
voice for the for the diaper thing. >> That is
Yeah, I agree.
>> But there was no other signs of like age play or anything.
I mean
>> that sounds like she trained him.
>> It is also a wildly easy voice to do.
I got that voice in my arsenal for other things. I don't think
of it as a baby voice. I think it was like a voice. It's like
it's a slight change up from just a total voice, right? >> Like
told us we look like really young and like he liked that we're
small and skinny and have no
not really super age play stuff. >> Hear me out for a second.
Would that not have a dark terrifying edge to it if he did it
a lot and the rest of the time he was beating your ass during?
No. No.
By the way, all that he's missing is clear and obvious consent
the first time he does it. And I
he's in some gray area after the first time where the relationship
continues and he's not told to stop and he does think that the
person is like into that thing, right? He did a baby voice while
beating your abs would be creepy. Yes. Also that. Also that.
Yes.
>> Yeah. That's true. That's true. That's true. Um, did
he ever come across as generally manipulative? Like just like,
you know, like a
general narcissistic stuff, like lying about stuff that doesn't
make sense, that doesn't need to be lied about.
>> No, just very upfront, very honest. >> Um, he
was manipulative about some situations. I mean, obviously he
lied to me about what he did at first. Um, he he did lie to me
about meeting Ellie.
Um, and I think that he was a very good liar and would and would
kind of twist stories a lot to make him look like the cool guy.
Um, one of an example I can give is one of his friends went to
the
because they got no ass or he's into age play with them now.
No, it's multiple women reporting that when they get undressed,
he goes, "Oh, you look like a kid. Awesome.
You look like a little girl. Awesome."
I I think it's that that's probably where people are like, "Oh,
this is weird. This is weird."
>> And he was like, "Well, if I hadn't noticed that my
friend was sick and took him to the hospital, he would have died.
So, basically, I saved his life."
>> Wow. and just like really narcissistic
like that that would kind of be like okay dude >> was there
any other weird like once off lines like that that was like that's
a bizarre thing to say.
>> I'm trying to really think of some and I'm sure I could
come up with more. Um but yeah, it was just stuff like that that
he would try to make him seem cooler than he really was, I guess.
>> Oh, you reminded me. He made a very interesting post
about how he seems to resent his career on YouTube and wants
to like start a rock band as a as a
>> Yes, that is 100% true.
>> How often did he bring up the the rockstar fantasy?
>> Oh, all the freaking time. Like he was like, "Oh, I'm
just so burnt out with work. I hate what I'm doing. I just I
feel like there's I'm just creating more drama and like I'm doing
nothing with my life with this YouTube channel because I'm just
talking about, you know, people who have their life up and I'm
just, you know, it's doesn't really mean anything, but I want
to be
>> That's true. >> like Panta and be like
uh
create my own genre. That's what he said. He wanted to create
his own genre of music in which he is both the frontman and lead
>> Did he actively
pursue this in any way or did he just like talk about it as like
a fantasy?
>> And it' be super cool if I was like the head of a band
I I sung and I was league guitar. That'd be super cool. >> Um
he bought a guitar but he like never played it. He just bought
a guitar.
>> That's sad. >> That's relatable.
>> At least Oh, okay. >> Donated $3 rock band a Tom
Petty LOL.
>> Okay. Thank you, Ruben. Ruben, thank you. I'm happy
that
Null said that was relatable because I do think pretty much everybody's
done that before where they're like, I you buy a guitar. I did
this when I was like 15. And I bought a guitar and I was like,
I'm going to learn to play guitar. I never played that guitar.
I bought a guitar. I like worked at my job. I eventually bought
a guitar. I was like, I'm going to learn to play the guitar.
And then I never touch that guitar.
Okay. I think I think a lot of people have done that before.
Can we stick to the abuses?
Why are we roasting them for that? Hey, that's literally what
this is. This is literally about roasting people. That's what
it is, man. >> Thing to do, buy something like I'm going
to learn how to master this. You just never do it. Um, so he
just felt like his his work had had no like actual value or meaning.
>> That's sad. Did he How often did he like talk about
his work? You you said you asked him about specific people and
stuff like did he seem like he hated talking about it? Like I
don't want Dude, do I do I go in on null here a little bit?
Oh, Turkey Tom didn't like his work.
That's sad.
All of his work is based on your work. Like all of his work is
based on your
>> What do you mean that's sad? >> I don't even want
you to have your mind routed by this internet drama stuff. >> He
would hate when I called him Turkey Tom. Like he would be like,
"Don't call me that."
>> I would joke around with him and be like, "Oh, Turkey
Tom, like Thanksgiving for turkey." And he would be like, "Don't
call me that." >> That's very funny.
>> was it was it No. Was it really funny? I mean, outside
of that, like there was never like any >> Bro, is this
guy Is this guy trying to ri right now? That wasn't funny. You
You really You're trying to ri right now. >> Just ongoing
discussion about like what he was up to >> like on the
internet, you mean? Or
>> Yeah. Like,
oh, did he ever like vent like, "Oh man, I'm working on this
thing." It's like it's so stupid. Like, did he like fill you
in on what he was doing dayto day? >> Oh, yeah. He would
be he would be like, "Yeah, I'm working on this video, you know,
it's about so and so." and he would kind of try to explain whatever
the heck he was working on the video about to me and he would
be like, "Oh, it's just taking forever." And like he would have
someone else also, I don't know if this is public information
or whatever, but he wouldn't really write his own stuff. He would
pay other people to write it for him.
>> How much if do you know how much of the work did he
actually do? I know he had an editor cuz he puts together these
huge videos, right? So, and he makes a ton of money. So like
why not have an editor? But was it like completely
sourced from people in Disord
tell me about the content farm? Tell me
the TT Jeets. Okay. The Turkey Tom Jeets.
Tell me about the Indian content farm now. God damn it. Why did
Stardust have to complain about that? Now I'm going to be racist.
Now she she complained about me being racist and now I'm just
going to lean into it. That's >> [__] writing
team. Did he have like did he just do the voice over? Basically,
>> he would he would do editing on his own
>> Who's going to trust these chicks after this? Um, well,
the what do you go? The Sacramento girl is like 20 and apparently
she's hot. Let me get I'm guessing like 99.95%
of the male population on the earth. Probably. She She's probably
lost. 05% of the male population. He's like a 20-year-old hot
girl. Okay. videos. But yeah, he would basically just read out
whatever he had written for him, like the script. >> But
he did the editing and like putting together like the the screenshots
and stuff, the videos.
>> dude. He's been content milling out for a long time.
He just does the voiceovers. That's it. That's all he does. Tom
Tom could do all of the things. That's the thing is like I don't
feel that weird weirded out by Tom having like um his what do
you call it is like content mill going because Tom did figure
out how to do all that stuff himself. He did spend a long time
edit editing and like I don't know
like he has people who look at him as like a really good video
editor, right? He spent all the time learning how to do it, mastering
the craft and then he moved on to doing other stuff once he made
money doing it. I don't know. It seems like not that bad. >> You
go first. >> Um, he told me apparently that he had fired
a bunch of his editors and so he would do all the editing,
but um,
he would still pay people to like collect everything and write
up a script for him.
Yeah, that removes some of the joy from it if you don't have
any interest in the subject whatsoever and are just voicing over
videos at that point.
>> I'm not sure. So after you guys you guys broke up in
December, so only a month ago,
and then there was how many weeks between
that and deciding to like post on the forum? And what was like
the motivating factor? Cuz uh for posterity sake, if you're listening,
um like in the future, the Kiwi Farms right now has been like
under an attack for the last couple months. So, I've had the
at the gates is what I think it's called, if I remember that
correctly. It's like a there's like a who signs up for Kiwi Farms.
He He's like a He's like a scriptor. He's He's a programmer or
scriptor or something. And he's built like a botnet to sign up
to Kiwi Farms and just spam child in all of the threads
and and it's like shut the it like has been over all of Null's
time apparently.
This is like a who literally spams child in all of the threads.
He makes new accounts and then he spams child in the threads
and null's like continuing to come up with ways to like dodge
this guy spamming child in all the threads on the site >> to
disable registrations without invitation code. And you did you
had to email me to get a invitation code. So I I actually I had
to vet you. So you sent me like multiple pictures and one was
like you're covering your mouth and the other one >> Yeah.
He's basically just got like nobody can sign up for the site
right now
because there's a just spam child if you have open signups. Like
he'll just figure out how to get around the open signups and
then he's got all the bots set up to go through. >> Tommy,
you have sunglasses on. I'm like I can't even see like an entire
picture of your face at this point because because of how you
set them. But you actually you went out to your car in like the
middle of the night to get your sunglasses so I could confirm
that it was like the same sunglasses in this picture. So it it
wasn't like a split decision where you're like, "Okay, I'm going
to join on this forum and like dump all this stuff." It was like
a really deliberate action. So what was like the igniting factor
for that?
>> Um it was talking to Katie and realizing
>> um I wasn't the only person that he had done this to
and that made me kind of realize like oh [__] like
he's gonna be out there doing this to more people and it's bad.
So yeah, that's kind of what made me want to come out because
I realized that I'm not alone and also if I have another person
with me who has been through the same thing, it'll I mean, you
know, strength and numbers.
>> Yeah, it is. It is kind of shocking to me that like
he's cuz it's over multiple years and he's just having like this
completely like passionless, joyless like like humping sessions
that are like really violent and it's like but he's just that's
just like what he does apparently. It's his even long-term relationships
like that's how he just prefers to do it. That's really really
>> Yeah. But there was no like specific like did you guys
talk at all between then between breaking up and
>> um I dude that's also reading like so much in it doesn't
have to be passionless like he could he pro he gets something
out of it. I don't know they're like
I don't know. I feel like he gets something out of it then >> right
obviously. >> Um Tom and I
>> I don't believe so cuz I blocked him. Um, as soon as
I was going to post, I did let him know. And I was like, um,
I'm just going to
see. I'm just going to post about everything that happened. So,
yeah. And then I blocked him.
>> Okay. The only other questions I'd have would be like
super petty and catty stuff that people would want to hear. So,
do you feel like there's anything that wasn't mentioned that
is like super important? Like any real important event in that
timeline? cuz it just sounded like you guys were hooking up like
once every week and kind of had this long-term thing and then
after a while it just got kind of weird cuz he was like very
obviously talking to other women and then after you started digging
into him more
and my my take on this by the way was that after you found out
about the Kiwi Farms the the the power dynamic of the relationship
just completely like equalize. It's like if she knows about this
drama website, then I don't really have I can't like be mean
to her. I can't really do anything anymore. So, it kind of lost
interest because of that where it's like if I have like this
normal person who has no internet presence whatsoever, I can
do whatever I want and then if she doesn't like it, all she can
do is like leave, right? But then it's like once once you found
out about like the whole ecosystem
down there, it's it just it's over for him and he can't get into
it anymore.
I agree. I think that it was I hate to be like those people who
are like, "Oh, power dynamics, blah, blah, blah, but it was definitely
a big thing for him." And knowing that I have like found this
place where people have just openly talked about him and I found
all of this dirt about him, I think it just ruined his like ego
thing that he had going on.
Bro, it's not even uh maybe it's pos it's possible it did cuz
it Yeah, null has been driving narrative this entire time. It's
possible that if with him that she learned about Kiwi Farms.
I'm telling you in my mind,
he probably will never say so. I feel like the medication thing
I feel like that's true. Okay, dude. I don't
I don't know, man.
I think I think Tom is Yeah, I I don't think I think they're
just totally making this up to be honest with you. I think he
basically
it's
it could conceivably be that he felt like this girl was really
really distrustful and he didn't like that and then she went
to Kiwi Farm's like what's this? He's like oh multiple points
of you being really distrustful. Yeah, you
um also I don't know if I'm going to do more time. So thank you
for advertising for me but I don't know if I'm going to do more
time. If you guys want to donate, you can donate, but I don't
think I'm doing more time tonight. I had to get up super early.
I had to like shift up my sleep schedule so I could go drive
a whole bunch today and get a whole bunch of done. So, I showed
up. We showed up, but I'm pretty tired. So, >> um because
obviously from what I've seen, every single woman
usually either didn't either knew who he was or found out very
quickly who he was. and that's the only reason why they ended
up sleeping with him. So, I think that that gave him a really
big ego.
>> Okay, then I guess
that's basically it
>> Wait, a whole bunch of this stuff is almost certainly
true. Stephen Jellian, I'm saying that last bit of narring I
don't really think fits >> anything
timelinewise. I guess now if you don't mind um let me know if
you get bored or don't want to answer something but uh many people
have many questions. I see one person's asking that they want
to know if Turkey Tom selfharmed. Apparently there's an allegation
that he was like a cutter or something. Do you do you see any
of that? >> He told me that he had cut himself but I didn't
see any scars and I did not see a carving in his chest of any
sort or anything.
And so >> yeah, I never thought that was fake because of
how it was released, but apparently that's real. He confirmed
>> I never saw a carving on him like and I met him pretty
soon after the whole situation.
And then and like he told me that he had self harm before, but
I like didn't see any scars on him and so I thought maybe he
was just doing that to like try to like be like me too, girl.
>> Okay. I mean, that sounds like that verifies it then.
That's crazy. I I'm
Um,
oh, and one other thing I I forgot about this, but you actually,
uh, Sacramento had sent me a picture that was like censored.
Um, apparently the only picture that he would send you is one
where his face isn't clearly visible in it, but you can I can
tell the desk like his computer is moved onto the table, but
I can still see like the monster is like on the the cozy that's
like on the table like in the exact same position. So, I can
tell that's clearly his desk. And you sent it to me because he's
grabbing your face in such a way that um the picture I showed
of the
>> Oh, that was from Sacramento. I wait >> on um
Katie's face is the exact same position. Like that bruise matches
up precisely with how he's grabbing you. So >> I see.
>> that's that's what I saw. Um cuz
>> I kind of want to see that picture. Not because
not for like any reason other than it I I guarantee it's going
to look the same as that Cameron F305 picture with the um
Oh, what is her name? The girl that Cameron F305 choked.
Oh, why can't I think of it? It's like Cran Krenaxia. Crexia.
Crexia. Krexa. Krexa.
Yeah, it's going to be like um it's going to be like the Cam
Crexa thing. Cam 305.
Uh Cameron F5 Crexa thing. Yeah, that's what it's going to be
like. It's going to be that kind of cringe thing where he's like
doing the he's like trying to show dominance, but it just looks
really >> He didn't want to post it in public. So, I I
vetted it indirectly by saying, "Yeah, it's definitely him."
That's because his hair is very distinct. He has that swish hair
like like Bieber, I guess. I don't know if that's mean to >> but
he has that hair. He has the uh the >> the emo bang.
>> Yeah. Uh, and he's he's grabbing in a very distinct
way that would leave a thumbrint if it was very very hard.
Um,
on that note, um, did he ever talk [__] about any
of his YouTube friends in in particular Nicholas Dioro? Did he
ever say I >> No, I can't even remember him ever talking
about someone named Nick or
>> He talked about Nick in passing to me, but never like
anything bad. He was just like, he would talk about like, "Oh,
my YouTube friend Nick. Sorry guys." >> He never he never
spoke at length about like anybody like streamed with or
>> Not really. >> Not really.
>> How big was his
>> Oh my god. >> Oh my god.
>> Can we plead the fifth on this one? I don't want to
get That's That can't be his own.
Null's dropped all Null's dropped all pretense here. He's dropped
everything. Okay. He's dropped every
every He's dropped all of it. Okay. He's just like, "Okay."
He before he was like angling around. He wanted to say it like
in the same way. Like he wanted to stick on topic. Now he's just
like, "We hit the end of the
How big's this dick? How big? How big's this dick? Show me. Show
me." >> That'll always look good for him. You have to say
it's shaped like an egg. That's That's >> hella [__]
up, guys. It's been all types of ways. It look like it looks
like a Z. >> Let's see if there's anybody else. So, no
no [__] talking that would be funny to relay. I guess
him doing with Dick Mastersonson and knowing that that I don't
know how you carry conversation with somebody knowing that he
has a butt plug in. That's a bit weird. >> That is so funny.
>> Why is Kick being gay? I can see live on kick but not
on live on Twitter but not on Kick. I have no idea, man.
I'll be honest. I might not even make it. We might be rolling
timed up tomorrow as well. We might have to roll an hour to tomorrow.
I
am so tired right now. I tried drinking a bunch of caffeine.
It's not helping. I'm like
>> I think you should tell them that he wasn't uh he wasn't
accepted into the Catholic church.
Oh my gosh.
>> How did he get rejected from the church?
>> I'm I'm a Catholic and he grew up Catholic. So, I decided
to try to take him to church with me, even though he's kind of
like a turbo godless atheist.
Um, and he decided to go to church wearing his like usual homeless
attire. And, um, when he went up to go get communion from the
priest, the priest was like,
"Uh, you're not Catholic. Don't come and take communion."
And he was being very disrespectful the whole time during mass
and decided to start taking Zins during service. And >> really
what the dude Auggie Auggie just Auggie heard that and he was
like, "Oh,
okay. This guy got to go. This guy got to die now." Augie Auggie
is not going to be happy about that.
He disrespected the Catholic mass. Auggie, what now? What now?
Auggie,
what are you going to What's going to happen now, man? That's
a red flag if anyone doesn't like if you're trying to like bring
somebody into like your social circles and they're just that
disinterested and passive aggressive and like that's a bad
>> Oh, I didn't even mention this, but you you talked about
how he I don't even know what these are. Z is like a
>> Zen is it?
>> Okay. They said zins.
You said zine
as in you know what a zen is
like wait unless did they send a picture cuz cuz for me they
said zins and unless you know the the text z yn z yn okay
why would you go z why would you say z why that mean they already
said zins if you just didn't know what they are why would you
say a different word like that's like somebody saying to me
Uh, that's like somebody saying to me like, "Do you like jalapenos?"
And I'm like, "No, I don't like gelapinos."
It's like, "Wait, why would you know how to say it that way?"
Or, "Sorry, not that. Um, no, I don't even know what jelapenos
are." It's like, how do you know the the pronunciation to misspeak
it
Sorry, how do you know the the spelling to mispronounce it phonetically?
How do you know that? It's like a hint, dude. It's a >> nicotine
pouch. It's kind of like a dip. It's almost like if you made
dip into like it's like the It's like dip but like vape flavors.
So it's like not to like not chewing tobacco. It's like these
little nicotine pouches and they have like fun flavor. >> Fumbled
that analogy. I mean the analogy was perfect. I just fumbled
speaking it. I fumbled bringing it into existence. It makes perfect
sense though. >> Do you have to spit it out or is it like
a dissolving thing? >> You spit it out. And so that's when
people question the fact that I said he had a Zen volcano, but
I am not kidding. He had a like pile. >> He would >> of
them. >> He would spit it out on like the floor next to
his desk >> on like on the little cap of it and he would
have like a 3-in tall like little pile of like these dirty used
Zins that have been in his mouth. >> Oh, that's [__]
up. I didn't even know what they were. I was like, "Okay, so
he has like a pile of like ecigarettes. Who cares?" That's really
[__] up. That's really gross. You said his room in
was like in like apparently his house he has a mansion but it's
completely barren except for his his like dungeon editing studio
and then it's like trash, right?
>> So that was his house in Maine. He was when I met him
in Texas, he he basically just had like this vacant house in
Maine the entire time. Um
>> then he went to Texas and was like I'm gonna be a human
being and got to >> since he's been here. and he was living
in his friend's mansion for a while and he was like living in
the the the
>> It it was a very weird setup but yeah
>> in the kitchen. >> He was living in the kitchen.
>> I don't know how to describe. There was like a side
room that was like a little mini kitchen that he was like living
in.
Gross. People want to see a picture of the the the Zen Mountain.
Do you have this? I'm I'm trying. I don't know if I've taken
any.
>> I'll have to look. >> Okay. If you find the the
mountain, people people want to see it. They want to see the
filth and depravity. They're very interested. Um, someone asked
there was two things. And forgive me, I I forgot what Katie had
said, but someone asked if why did you threaten Tom with going
public before doing it? I'm not >> like did you just want
him to know? Like did any did you say don't do this or I'll go
public and then he did it or
>> or did you just decide >> I told him like don't
do anything or I'll go I was just like I'm going to go public
and that's when he told me uh oh I'm scared of what Kiwi Farms
is going to do to you and I was like well you I guess we'll find
out. >> Well we're very scary. Um
the the uh what Katie, what did you say that like set off a bunch
of his friends that were streaming? I haven't been watching their
streams, so I don't know what their talking points are, but apparently
you said something in a forum post that like upset them or like
they honed in on
>> What did I I don't even know. I haven't been keeping
up that much, so I don't I don't know what. And also, I hate
all these slop tuber freaks and so
>> I have no idea what people are mad about.
Tell someone in the chat to to say what it >> Sloptuber
freaks are the only people who believe you, [__]
How about you show a little respect? How about you show a little
respect?
Sloptuber freaks are the only people who believe you. Everyone
else is just like, "No, you're lying."
uh if you have an idea of what I'm talking about, let me know.
Actually, that's a great follow-up question. Why me? Cuz I didn't
I did not proposition you guys. Like, do you guys want to come
on stream? It came kind of came out of nowhere. You asked me
like what my opinion was on Turkey Tom and I kind of like gave
you a very very long rundown on my opinion of like Turkey Tom
in that situation and then afterwards you were >> do you
want to do a a stream thing and like sure you even explicitly
said that you hate the other streamers. So I'm I'm curious what
led to that decision. I feel like you've been very nice to us
and I don't also I really do not want a bunch of these weirdo
YouTubers who have reached out to us to like make money off of
our stories and try to like twist it into some big giant
>> drama thing. I mean they've just been so like disrespectful
about everything. So >> and weird.
>> What? I have not been weird. Do you feel like they're
holding back? I'm not entirely like caught up on like the social
web of these people, so I don't know like who's friends with
who, but apparently I think it was one of you guys that said
that he is like a social organizer in like conventions. >> I
don't know anything about that.
I think a I mean a lot of these people are saying like [__]
[__] I feel like because they're like for one Gooners
themselves. The one video I watched the guy was like I can't
hate Turkey Tom. I'm a fan and I'm a gooner, too. So, and I was
like, "All right, what the fuck?" And so, I don't know that.
And then also, so maybe because he's big and everything and he's
friends with all the other like bigger commentary people, people
like they're scared to like
go much
>> from my perspective cuz I I don't I don't have internet
friends. Like, none of these people like me. So, >> I don't
know who any of these people were until like this week. I feel
like having Tom as a friend is probably like a really big boon.
So, they're caught in this awkward position where they want to
be like on the right side of where this falls out, but then on
the other hand, they don't want to like preemptively jump Tom
and like lose him as a friend because he is a like a financial
benefit and like a social tiein. So, they're caught in this awkward
position where it's like the the internet collective, the mob
wants blood and they want these people who give people blood
to give them what they want. But then on the other hand, they're
like, "Well, if I screw up and, you know, I I go all in and then
Tom cuts me off and I'm wrong," then it's like, "Yeah, they would
feel bad about that." So, they're kind of trying to play both
sides, which is the least interesting position to take. >> Yeah,
I'm seeing a lot of >> Wow. Okay, here we go. >> Okay,
that's what I was looking for. I >> Oh, man. Dude,
I literally I was sitting here. I mean, he I don't know if I
agree with that
I think there are some people doing that
but not I don't know there's like lazy slop tubers who are doing
that maybe like um sensitive society more Pegasus these people
but you know Nick went live talked about it
I don't know doesn't seem that bad I went to go see how much
Null was making doesn't make that much money off of streams dude
he didn't even get he didn't even break 100 sorry he barely broke
$100 probably American
on that stream for super chats dude Dude, none of the Kiwi Farms
people pay him. What the >> Nobody in the thread clarified,
I don't think, about what you had. >> He's on kick though.
He probably could see some money on kick. >> Annoyed people.
But yeah, the Oh, the only other thing I can think of that's
kind of like gossip that you might have insights on, um, I asked
you if he was like or heter heteroplexible at any point, but
um, did he ever show any interest in transgender people? Because
apparently he paid for somebody's transgender surgery or that
was like a
>> Do Do you know anything about this?
>> No, I I don't. I do believe he's and if somebody could
repost this or bring this up on the thread because there is a
video of him talking with I think this guy Monkey Monkey Jones
and he he just flat out said I'm
um so I don't really >> well I don't know if we were watching
the Monkey Jones one but we definitely watched him say some video
before >> know how like he could deny it but he was No,
they're talking about >> I'm definitely interested in like
men and especially like bodybuilding men.
So,
I don't know about the trans thing though, like never talked
about trans stuff at all.
>> I somebody asked if
uh you had any intention of getting any sort of like law enforcement
involved, but I feel like feel like you answered this where you
just want to try to compel him to delete whatever he has on you
and that's like the me like the extent of your interest.
And if he I mean if he doesn't I mean I I don't know. I really
I'm kind of confused about what to do, but we'll
>> Well, from my understanding, I'm not a lawyer, but as
I as I told you by email, um there are victim advocacy groups,
and because you're both in the same state, that makes things
a lot simpler. That will help you. Um, but as far as the law
goes, as far as I know, you can't really compel someone to delete
something, but there is a federal law
>> um that creates a way to sue somebody if they publish
it without your consent. >> I guess you should just make
it clear to
I mean, I guess I don't know if you've already made it clear
to him, but you should make it really clear to him and like screen
cap saying that that you don't want him to share anything that
you have that he has on you because uh if he does do it, you'll
know it's him. And it is
>> I I think it's $250,000
statutory per image. And as I mentioned in the email, it is a
um is what
I I think it's $250,000
statutory per image.
I don't believe that's true. I don't I don't believe that's true
for Cardi.
Maybe I'm way off. I don't think I think that's the maximum penalty
for Cardi or
for the normal damages.
I think that's the max, not the minimum. >> And as I mentioned
in the email, it is a
um is it has a fee what's called a fee shifting provision. And
>> yeah, it's like the max statutory damages that you could
be awarded, right? There are statutory damages, but I do believe
that it's not like a the minimum is probably I think it's 5k
or
I the minimum is not that low. Sorry, not that high. I think
the maximum is 250. And this is very rare in our our law. But
if you sue him and win or prevail at all, even if you don't get
$250,000,
he owes your attorney's fees, too, which is a huge thing. And
it's very hard to find a law that has that. So, it's really in
your favor. It would be a very He can ask Destiny cuz Destiny
is being sued for the exact same thing at this exact moment about
how much fun it is to be sued for revenge. Okay.
Anything else? >> No, I think that's about it, Katie. Yeah,
I don't really have anything.
I think we went through everything.
>> Okay.
Any
any final words? Any words of wisdom? I have some. You don't
have any? Don't worry. I'm not leaving you up. >> Don't
talk to YouTubers.
>> Yeah, do not talk to weird YouTubers. And if he hits
you or chokes you, you need to just break it off immediately
and run away as soon as possible instead of being a dumbass and
saying >> it is not normal.
>> Yeah, 150 is the cap on statuto damages. >> there's
no fixing that. You don't feel like there's a
>> I guess it can I I had a conversation with him years
ago when he was first getting big and then I think he lost interest
in me and moved over to Destiny. I don't know. Maybe he got different
vibes from Destiny. Something that he was interested in. But
um I that's like a petty jealous ex way to describe that. Null.
That was really weird of you. Uh Turkey Tom used to be friends
with me and then he like started to hang out with Destiny and
then he didn't want to hang out with me anymore and uh maybe
he got something from Destiny he didn't get from me.
>> I warned him. I said that the first way to up everything
you've built is to screw around with girls because that's like
the
>> Oh, what kind of girls? Josh. >> Josh, finish
the sentence. Josh, what kind of girls? >> I don't know
what it is. There's something about like relationship drama where
it's like if you know that that's how somebody treats somebody
when they think it's completely private. It gives you kind of
like an insight into how they perceive interpersonal relationships
and how they're how they would treat you if they could get away
with it. I feel like that's kind of why people care about stuff
like that cuz it's kind of like an insight to how somebody really
is. >> Um, but
I could also say this, never goon. This this this for sure for
>> think this interview will help Tom. I don't think this
interview helps Tom. Um, the interview is embarrassing for Tom.
I do think null's a weirdo, but I don't think it's better for
Tom. I think I mean I guess I don't understand the mind of like
the turkey, sorry, the the like Willie Mack viewer, like the
sensitive society viewer. It's possible I just misread, but it
seems like I I don't think this really hurts them. I think Clorox
Katie is a little too into it. The other girl has like negative
reasons, but I didn't get the impression she was lying. Didn't
feel like she was lying about like the actions Tom did. some
of her reasoning. When she has to explain her actions, I do feel
like she's lying. When she has to explain what Tom's done, it
feels
>> Sure, it's addiction. He is straight up lying to you
if he's saying that he's not watching cuz this is like textbook
stuff and it's just like >> that's exactly what I thought.
I was I was just like from the get I was like, "Oh, this is like
Gooner activity like
>> Yeah. Okay. Well, I guess that's it then. I didn't didn't
see anything else that was too interesting. So, uh you guys did
great in case you're wondering. Um my last interview, as she
told you, was with Channing Kger, who uh was drunk and on heroin
and uh collapsed within a couple minutes. So,
>> Oh, Christmas example. >> Christmas example. Yeah,
I'm very NLK day example today and it's it went much better.
I'm very pleased. Um, thank you for your time. Thank you for
reaching out to me. I appreciate it. And if that's everything,
uh, good luck.
>> Thank you. Thank you for being so nice.
>> Thank you. Bye.
>> Wow, what an interview.
All right. >> Okay. All right, everyone.
That was cool. Um, I would do takeaways and I will maybe come
up with takeaways for tomorrow. I think new stuff. I'm trying
to think of like new stuff.
Um, just more confirmation of like the the worst details, right?
I do think this like it
to me I do think there's probably,
you know, more leaning into the age play stuff, more oh, what's
the big one? The non-consensual recording seemed pretty obvious.
Some of the stuff around how he like was super inconsiderate
of his partners is interesting as well.
We'll see. Did the caffeine kick? It did not kick. I'm going
to head out, man. I I got to go. No, I'm sorry. I do want to
do the ice drama and I will do it, but I think I'll have to do
it tomorrow. Nemo, I might end up going like way live way earlier
tomorrow cuz I'm
I'm [__] dead. Sorry. I had to get up really early
and then I drove like a couple hours and I had to drive home
a couple hours and
it's rough, man. It's rough. It's rough. Okay,
so
yeah, it is what it is, man. Wenttos on Tim Pool. I heard about
that. probably not doing it tonight.
We'll have lots of content for tomorrow though, guys. We got
Fontes on Tim Pool. We've got the ice beside drama. Also, this
will let us add more time for tomorrow to do more of the ice
beside stuff, right? Like that'll develop overnight, over the
day, and then we'll have a lot more stuff we'll be able to do.
Okay. Okay.
All right. I am I'm sorry. I am like I I did say
that I was going to probably not be here, okay, tonight. I said
I I wasn't sure if I was even going to be here at all. So, unfortunately,
that's going to be it for me, dog. That's going to be it for
me. I'm going to go to bed.
I'm going to bed. I'm going to bed. Temple is bad. Yeah, I would
expect it.
Okay. Yeah, I'm really tired. So, I'm going to go to bed. We'll
talk to you guys tomorrow. Okay, have a good night everybody.
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye. Good night. Good night.
Good